oh here we go again it's time for us to
take another crack at putting SCP 682 6
ft under once and for all if you've been
following this channel for any amount of
time then there's one thing you know for
certain SCP 682 is harder to kill than
pretty much well anything we've made
multiple videos on the foundation's
failed attempts to finally terminate the
Beast and we've made a video with some
of your ideas on how to finally slay the
monster and considering you're watching
this video right now you can probably
guess how that went now it's time for
one more run at the Death Star and once
again it's with your ideas from comments
and Community post responses let's see
if any of them can help us finally put
this ill-tempered reptile to rest if we
can't well we're not blaming you but
it's also your fault let the community
termination attempts commence anos
McBride suggested ask the witch child
SCP 239 also known as the witch child
this one of the most dangerous and
Powerful anomalies out there she's a
small girl with unparalleled reality
warping mental abilities so powerful
that her very brain waves alone can be
passively fatal however the problem is
her power is so potentially dangerous
that she's forever kept in a kind of
medically induced anomalous coma Dr Alto
thinks she's so dangerous he's even
campaigning to have her terminated as a
result the 05 Council has forbidden any
cross testing between 682 and 239
fearing the consequence of 682 gaining
239's powers and becoming a truly
Unstoppable threat capable of causing an
XK Class end the world scenario CAD
zamin Alisha kazimi musadi suggested
kill him with SCP 734 this is an
interesting one SCP 734 also known as
the baby is an anomaly that causes a
painful degenerative disease that
eventually disintegrates the entire body
and kills the victim if they so much as
come into contact with the baby or its
fluids however based on Cross tests with
other similar touch it and die anomalies
like SCP 409 the contagious Crystal we
can probably guess how exactly this
would go down in all likelihood the
baby's anomalous effects would infect
and Destroy large portions of SCP 682s
body however at this point 682 would
adapt to the threat and begin to reverse
it and heal even worse it's likely that
682 would steal the ability for a
limited time and become deadly to the
touch Kaden Griffin suggested why don't
you use the dragon slayer to terminate
682 it has proved itself many times in
fights with lsas SCP 5514 the dragon
slayer is essentially a giant fighting
robot designed to take down killer
kaijus with its plethora of
state-of-the-art anomalous weapons and
defenses however we'd still argue that
while it could definitely help in
immobilizing 682 during a rampage it
doesn't have much of a chance of
actually killing it let's look at SCP
001 the gate Guardian a supernatural
warrior with a blade hotter than the sun
capable of cleaving atoms in half even
he couldn't kill SCP 682 so robotic
approximation with only a fraction of
the gate Guardians power is probably not
going to have any real chance of killing
682 I'm a chuckster 48 suggested make it
bite its tongue so hard that it just
destroys itself while we can certainly
attest from personal experience that
this really really really hurts we worry
that if ever 682 bit its own tongue
really hard it' just drive it into a
state of murderous rage though we do
take a small piece of satisfaction and
knowing its tongue would probably be in
distress for a few minutes afterwards
it's unlikely to wipe out the Beast once
and for all lazyy Ro suggested how about
we just put SCP 682 in 2317 cell SCP
2317 is an old wooden door that
functions as a portal into the domain of
the planet destroying monster known as
the devour of Worlds a being that many
believe is associated with the Scarlet
King and will inevitably escape and
cause an XK Class end of the world
scenario while you may be thinking
perhaps it'll kill 682 it's more likely
that it'll collaborate seeing as they
both want the same thing namely to kill
everyone if you let 682 in chances are
it'll come back through the door with
the devour right on its tail then it's
all of our problems guest 1 23 1116
suggested drop him in Russia so they can
terminate him the foundation has
technically already tried this they
dropped 682 into SCP 3930 a patch of
literal non-existence in Russia that
causes anything that goes inside of it
to cease to exist and afterwards he was
fine so yeah dropping him anywhere in
Russia is probably just going to get a
bunch of innocent Russian civilians
killed Myer said the foundation
shouldn't worry about how to kill him
but how to stop his ability to adapt I
would suggest typing SCP 682 no
adaptability juice or something like
that into SCP 294 and then kill him by
any means which should kill him forever
an interesting Theory but what if he
simply adapts to SCP 682 no adaptability
juice then we'd really all be in trouble
Mario tgp said give him a Twitter
account he'll be canceled instantly for
his spicy opinions SCP 682 would cancel
Twitter itself for not having opinions
that are spicy enough
sorry Jack scp096 still sore about
losing the battle we assume said let him
fight the Queen of England after all
she's Immortal too we definitely think
it would be interesting to see SCP 682
go head-to-head with the Queen of
England based on all the nighting she
does we know that she at least has a
sword though we don't know if that sword
is as powerful as the one wielded by the
gate Guardian but regardless of the
outcome the battle would definitely
change history every history book would
simply read SCP 682 punched the queen
everything else would just be a footnote
Noah Cordo said use SCP 2935 to kill the
lizard as you can see in the video he
will die SCP 2935 also known as o death
is probably one of the scariest and
deadliest scps out there it killed an
entire alternate Dimension including an
alternate SCP
682 the problem is putting R 682 into
2935 is alternate reality could lead to
the destruction of our entire Dimension
why is that because if 682 was somehow
able to return to our world from the
world of
2935 it could bring the spirit of death
itself back with it and kill us all in
the process explorando cometto one
suggested SCP 682 versus lady deatri
while Resident Evil AIDS lady diatri has
certainly captured all of our hearts we
don't think she'll be bringing home the
W on this one lady de metri has a
powerful adaptive ability of her own
with a high resistance to damage
impressive regenerative abilities and a
number of offensive capabilities from
huge claws to a powerful Dragon form
however considering she wasn't able to
defeat Ethan winter she probably
wouldn't be able to defeat SCP 682
either however in her Dragon form SCP
682 May finally join the rest of us in
developing a crush or is that being
crushed anyway moving on Jonathan peeky
suggested just ask SCP 343 on how to
destroy it or even better ask if he
could destroy it it's an idea so good
that the foundation actually tried it
and it went about as well as you can
expect when the SCP known as God entered
the containment chamber he couldn't even
see 682 in there as though the creature
was somehow totally invisible to him
when God eventually got bored and left
they told him that he was in there to
destroy 682 he simply replied he's not
one of mine deal with him yourself
interpret that how you will 12 Escobar
Blancas Eddie Saul suggested they could
send him to area 37 for the Sisters to
experiment with SCP 1765 the sisters are
a trio of terrifyingly powerful reality
warpers that have taken over area 37 and
spend their days tormenting everyone
inside with their Twisted experiments
using them to try to terminate 682 leads
to similar problems with using the witch
child or the devour of Worlds if they
decide to team up rather than fighting
or the sisters take over 682 we'd all be
effectively doomed kirya suggested with
the ants from SCP 743 tear 682 apart the
foundation actually tried this getting
682 to consume chocolate from the SCP
743 Fountain incurring the wrath of its
flesh eating ants however 682 developed
an adaptation that gave it a long anater
like tongue that it then used to consume
the ants faster than they could consume
it and even worse the chocolate seemed
to enhance its regenerative abilities
even more for several days afterwards
ball 2222 suggested write the name in
The Death Note great idea we'll put it
into practice as soon as you can tell us
as CP 682s real name it may come as a
surprise but its parents didn't actually
name it the hardto destroy reptile
Steven ver suggested I thought that
maybe we should put him in a giant
blender and then when he's in small
pieces put lava in the blender so it
we'll incinerate him then put nuclear
waste into the blender and repeat that
until there's no more left of him after
the cooking whis last time we feel
obliged to include at least one attempt
to kill SCP 682 with oversized kitchen
equipment in every video about him
however this attempt would probably go
about as well as the last one were
afraid extreme physical trauma by
conventional means like burning and
dismemberment has never been successful
in the past and the foundation is
extremely hesitant to use anything
Radioactive on the beast in in case it
adapts and adds deadly radiation to its
own Arsenal Mr Master IQ suggested just
take away his plot armor you can pry SCP
682s plot armor from its cold dead Claws
and as we've already learned making
those claws cold and dead seems next to
Impossible moving on jc3 suggested hm if
anyone can't beat the undying lizard why
not omn man I mean he did kill all the
Guardians of the globe of course he can
kill SCP 682 omn man from the comic and
TV series Invincible is undeniably a
formidable opponent given he's able to
destroy superhero teams cities and even
planets however one of the few enemies
to give omn man a genuine run for his
money is a Genetically Enhanced Kaiju
known as Hail Mary given that first 682
has taken on being stronger than omn man
like the gate guardian and lived and
second that omn man has struggled with
monsters before chances are he probably
couldn't permanently kill this one
either hean Havas suggested kill SCP 053
then 682 will be sad and die wow now
that's cold blooded however even if this
did work it's important for you to
remember that it's impossible to
actually kill SCP 053 also known as the
child or the little girl part of her
anomalous abilities is that anyone who
attempts to kill her will themselves
immediately die during the process
normally due to a heart attack so this
method would result in a pile of dead
Foundation personnel and no progress
Jerry Jang said mush peanut butter on it
this would definitely work if 682 had
some kind of severe peanut allergy after
all anaphylactic shock is no laughing
matter however in the far more likely
event that this will have no effect on
SCP 682 you will likely just die with
your hands covered in peanut butter
Andrew Mill suggested my idea have
several Xenomorphs predators and Dolls
yes that's the Doctor Who reference take
682 on once again in all likelihood this
would have no effect 682 has survived
blades and lasers the Primary Weapons of
the Predators and dolls and spends the
majority of its life immersed in
powerful acid so the xenomorph would
hold no surprises for it sadly this
three-way team up would be no match for
682 and even if it did defeat him
whoever wins we um well you know how it
goes Mato Quang suggested maybe just
destroy reality this this might be the
thing that finally kills SCP 682 but
considering it's already survived being
thrown into pure nothingness in Russia
it may just result in it being one of
the only survivors of a full destruction
of reality we on the other hand would
all be killed though in a sense we
wouldn't have to deal with that SCP 682
anymore so maybe that's a type of
winning and finally blind honor
suggested would saitama be a good way to
eliminate it he is one punch man after
all of anyone we've covered in this
series series saitama from one punch man
would probably be the most likely to
kill SCP 682 especially if he was taking
the battle seriously after all he has
killed Planet destroying monsters before
with barely any effort the only real
question is whether he could be bothered
to come down to a foundation containment
site and fight it saitama hasn't been
known to be a very motivated guy but of
course like with anything there's the
risk that 682 would survive and gain his
powers which would be bad awesome but
bad do you have new ideas for how SCP
682 could be killed do you think you
have the key to finally bringing this
Beast to a well-deserved end let us know
down in the comments and keep an eye on
our community post for more SCP
questions like this one so you can be
featured in the next video there is
something maddening about a repetitive
consistent sound don't you agree the
narrator of Edgar Allen Poe The Telltale
Heart is driven mad by the non-stop
beating of a heart coming from from
beneath his floorboards but even
something less horrible than a
disembodied heartbeat can Fray a
person's nerves superficially less
horrible anyway something as simple as
say the Relentless ticking of a clock
after all what could be more frightening
than a reminder of the sands of time
passing through our fingers of the
finite steps on life's long and winding
road we have the answer to that question
the scariest thing of all is the monster
waiting on the other side of the road
twisted and hungry the thing that
strikes when the ticking eventually
stops when time is up tick tock tick
talk many years ago a clock maker in the
German Town of fryberg was renowned for
his ability to produce Exquisite
personalized clocks for his clientele
all across town the country and even
Beyond his unparalleled constructions
made him the only man to reach out to
when it came to getting your hands on a
beautiful ornate time piece that would
ease the anxieties of the passing hours
he ate slept and breathed clocks it was
his life his calling as such the clock
maker had grown accustomed to the sound
of ticking he heard it in the morning
when he awoke to The Cry of his cuckoo
clock he listened to it all day in his
Workshop as he repaired and constructed
clocks of all shapes and sizes
and it was the sound that lulled him to
sleep at night after each long hard day
it gave life a pleasant Rhythm one day
however he noticed a particularly loud
repetitive sound had permeated his home
it was rhythmic like the ticking of his
clocks but harsher somehow it did not
gently tick but rather cracked like the
way his knees popped when a harsh winter
was coming something in it made his
stomach ache with Dread he began taking
apart every clock in his Workshop
looking for the source of the sound but
still it persisted he sat there at his
desk surrounded by gears and pieces of
wood Glass and Metal and still the sound
pounded against his eardrums tick talk
tick talk the clock maker was stumped by
The Mysterious Ticking Noise it felt too
real too Vivid to be some kind of
hallucinate ation he would have bet
every clock he ever made that the noise
was coming from outside of his head he
was a man so astute in his clock making
abilities that he could tell his own
Creations apart in the dark from the
mere Timber of their ticking but here he
was in the presence of an alien force
this frightening almost predatory sound
that lingered in his periphery always
somewhere but not confined to any fixed
point he was reminded vaguely of Peter
Pan of the crocodile that eaten Captain
Hook's hand and alarm clock which
survived and continued ticking in the
literal Belly of the Beast hook a
vicious pirate Captain would become a
gibbering wreck when the ticking sound
got closer did he fear the Predator whom
the ticking foretold or the passage of
time that pushed him further into the
Reaper's fold in the otherwise Immortal
plane of Neverland tick talk tick talk
the clockmaker search continued he
turned his workplace upside down and
inside out in pursuit of the seemingly
sourceless ticking he checked every
hiding place every closet cupboard cubby
hole and cabinet nothing he moved the
furniture tied up the curtains rolled up
all the carpets nothing in his
desperation he took a claw hammer from
his toolbox and began prying the rusty
nails from the ground before peeling up
the floorboards and checking the dusty
spider-infested spaces underneath
perhaps some mechanism had fallen down
there or had always been there just
ticking away there had to be something
down there but no only dirt insects and
shadows maybe he was going mad maybe it
was tonius or the indelible impression
that hearing years upon years of ticking
had left in his mind the way an image is
burned into a plasma screen if it's left
there for too long maybe it was some
shadowy government agency trying to
drive him mad with the use of some new
sound-based torture device oral
terrorism selective auditory subliminal
mind control Havana syndrome the
fizzling edges of Sanity egged On by The
Invisible longrange CIA telesound beams
there had to be some kind of explanation
but whatever the case the sound
persisted tick tock tick tock he
couldn't stay there in the dismembered
ruins of his prestigious clock making
shop any longer he was clearly under a
lot of stress here not healthy not good
for the mind he decided to close the
shop for a few days and go visit his
daughter and her family some time with
his beloved relatives would soothe his
frayed nerves so he packed his bag and
made the trip hoping that leaving work
behind for a few days would also loosen
up his mind but the entire drive to his
daughter's house he could have sworn he
still heard the sound keeping perfect
time as it cracked again and again he
shook his head scolding himself for
imagining things there was nothing in
the car that could be making that noise
he'd focused on it too much surely
that's why he was obsessing over it now
all this had a rational explanation he
simply thought to himself he'd simply
thought himself into a corner on this
one wouldn't that explain all of this
all just a trick in the mind of an
overworked clock maker sorely in need of
a good sabatical in the country this
wouldn't be forever TI talk tick talk
the clock Maker's daughter greeted him
at the door with a warm embrace and a
hearty meal and for a little while he
relaxed the sound of good company and
laughter drowned out the infernal
ticking he began to entertain the notion
that perhaps the ticking had been a good
thing it had been a long time since he'd
seen his daughter and that ticking as
frightening as it had been was also the
only thing that pushed him away from the
workshop for a while he was somewhat
grateful for a good excuse to take time
off perhaps that was what it was all
about a reminder to take it easy after a
weekend off he'd be right as rain surely
but that night as he tried to fall
asleep the sound was there again
taunting him keeping his eyes open wide
and his heart rate climbing was it the
Dark of the room magnifying his hearing
intensifying that awful ticking or was
it louder and closer than ever before
it felt as though an invisible clock
like so many he'd made before was
hanging over him but what was holding it
that awful awful sound like the bubbles
popping in the sovial fluids of a
person's aged and crumbling joints to
organic to fleshy and it just kept
getting louder and closer louder and
closer louder and closer tick talk tick
talk tick talk tick talk tick talk tick
talk until suddenly it went silent he
breathed a sigh of relief and closed his
eyes the clock Maker's daughter woke to
the sound of her father's piercing
guttural screams she ran to his room to
find the bed sheet soaked with blood the
bedroom window shattered and her father
Gone without a trace she went to the
police the next day but they could do
nothing for her her father had not been
the victim of an ordinary murderer or
Thief but something outside the realm of
understanding it was something ancient
something mysterious something monstrous
something anomalous though the police
could do nothing another organization
was secretly on the case the SCP
Foundation after The clockmaker
Disappearance operative searched the
area and discovered the culprit which
they captured and designated SCP 497 5
SCP 4975 is a humanoid entity with
birdlike features the most notable of
which is a sharp pointed beak its body
is long and thin with bony limbs with
tapered points with no discernable
digits of any kind its body including
its beak is covered with a thick hard
layer of skin the entity's most notable
feature is not its appearance however
but in its skeleton particularly its
spine the cervical vertebrae of the
creature are not not interconnected and
are capable of independent movement they
rotate one vertebra at a time from Back
to Front in order all the way up to the
entity's head in a particular Rhythm
this produces the clicking or cracking
sound that is so terribly familiar to
its intended victims it repeats the
motion constantly over and over again
only stopping when it's preparing to
attack its chosen prey SCP 4975 does not
kill impulsively simply selecting a
convenient victim instead it stalks its
prey for months at a time sometimes even
a year following them in darkness hiding
just out of sight the only sign of its
presence is that sound the clicking
cracking tick talk tick talk of its
bones as it bides its time knowing that
it can wait as long as it needs or wants
to before it strikes when it's ready to
Feast it will beat and tear at the
victim's body with the tapered points of
its limbs shredding the Flesh and
pecking at it much like a vulture rips
at a fresh carcass then it can Savor its
meal using the body as food for about 3
months before it needs to hunt again
though its exact age is unknown it is
theorized that the creature is hundreds
if not thousands of years old written
evidence of its existence has been
traced back as far as the 1500s there
are mentions of a creature resembling
SCP 4975 throughout German folklore
appearing in carvings paintings
folktales and nursery rhymes one such
nursery rhyme was discovered and
translated by the foundation during the
research process though its rhyme scheme
was lost when it was translated to
English the Eerie feeling it evokes was
not the rhyme goes tick talk the cuckoo
clock ticks cuckoo the bird inside sings
tick talk tick tock tick talk tick talk
as it ticks the time so ticks your heart
may you live long as you hear its song
Tick talk tick talk tick talk tick talk
listen close for when it stops the
hatchling comes out of its home tick
talk tick talk tick talk tick did you
hear it did it stop my child it meant
your time was up the research team
theorized that this nursery rhyme and
others like it was used to warn children
about potential indicators of danger
from SCP
4975 and teach them to be wary of its
hunting patterns knowledge after all is
one of the best weapons in anyone's
arsenal when it comes to the anomalous
without much more knowledge than this
little poem provides and what they had
observed prior to SCP 4975 capture the
SCP Foundation did its best to create
adequate containment measures for the
creature currently SCP 4975 is kept in a
standard steel containment cell and is
prohibited from any direct human contact
it can be observed via security footage
but no human beings are permitted to go
inside less they serve as the creature's
next meal if a Containment Breach occurs
any Personnel that report hearing a
repetitive cracking or ticking sound are
to be isolated until the entity has been
captured and placed back in its cell or
until the sound stops though SCP 4975 is
currently contained there is a chance
that its captive state does not actually
make it any less lethal after a
harrowing incident that sent many
attending researchers to the onside
psychologist's office the foundation was
given reason to believe that containing
it does not actually stop it from
hunting on September 16th 2002 something
horrible happened near the Black Forest
in Germany a team team of foundation
operatives had been placed in the area
to monitor a man from fryberg who had
complained to the local police about a
clicking sound that had been following
him around for quite some time over the
course of 4 months of being unable to
escape the sound or the feeling that he
was being watched no matter where he
went he had become convinced that
someone was stalking him it was a
bizarre situation and he wasn't certain
how his stalker was making this
maddening sound but he believed his life
to be in danger concerned that this
could be the work of SCP
4975 the foundation operatives took him
into custody the police were given a
cover story claiming that the man was
experiencing a sense of paranoia as well
as auditory hallucinations as a result
of side effects from chemotherapy once
the foundation operatives explained to
the man that they meant him no harm
believed him about his fears and wished
to help he opened up about his
experiences he told the operatives that
in addition to the sound and the feeling
of something something following him he
had seen a monstrous figure in the woods
he had kept the details to himself when
speaking to the police afraid they would
have him committed rather than listening
to him the operatives asked him to lead
them to the place where he had seen the
monster and he agreed the man led the
team to a densely wooded part of the
forest trees blocking out the sunlight
until their surroundings became as dark
as if it were the middle of the night as
they walked deeper and deeper into the
forest The Man became increasingly
anxious his breath came in short
strained gasps his eyes darted from tree
to tree and he jumped at the slightest
sound of a twig snapping beneath
someone's foot or branches rustling in a
gust of wind suddenly mid stride he
froze his eyes were wide his face was
white as a sheet with a trembling hand
he pointed toward a nearby Tree in a
voice so faint it was almost a whisper
he said s the operatives turned to look
but saw nothing there the man repeated Z
but they couldn't see anything but the
trees the man stumbled back going weak
at the knees from Pure Terror and
continued to point at the empty space
next to the tree just as one operative
was turning to another to comment that
their witness must be out of his mind
the man suddenly collapsed onto the
ground as if an invisible powerful force
had thrown him down the man screamed for
help struggling against the Unseen
attacker as it slashed at his face and
his chest tearing through Fabric and
skin blood spraying across the forest
floor two officers Drew their weapons
firing at where they guessed the asant
might be but their bullets ricocheted
uselessly off nearby tree trunks another
rushed to the man on the ground grabbing
him under the arms and attempting to
pull him out of Harm's Way however the
man would not budge as the invisible
force held him in place shredding
through his stomach as it fought to keep
its prey afraid to rip open the stomach
wound any further the operatives quickly
ceased his attempts to move the man
instead he pulled out his weapon and did
the only only merciful thing he could
think to do he shot the local man in the
head putting him out of his misery
before he was ripped to shreds the
operatives watched some in silent shock
some continuing to fire their weapons
some vomiting from sheer disgust as
strips of the Dead Man's flesh ripped
off of bone and disappeared one piece at
a time meanwhile thousands of miles away
surveillance footage of SCP 49 75's
containment site picked up some peculiar
activity in the creature's cell it
stopped rotating its neck which it had
done almost constantly since being
captured and stared at the corner of its
containment cell its eyes were wide
unblinking and it did not move a muscle
it stayed still for several minutes
until it eventually broke the unsettling
Stillness to eat greedily gobbling down
slices of meat there was one problem
though the creature had not yet been fed
that day all Foundation operatives
dispatched to Germany to investigate SCP
497 75 were recalled back to their
original sites an additional research
has been suspended until further notice
in light of this new information a
motion has been filed to reclassify the
creature as ker and potentially
impossible to contain with the
foundation's current resources as
terrible as it is to admit this is one
monster the foundation has not yet found
a way to stop they may have it locked in
a cage but it can still hunt anyone
anywhere anytime it wants to with wait a
second sh be very very quiet what's that
sound in your room right now listen
closely sh tick tick do you hear it
don't worry it's probably just a clock
or a kitchen timer maybe it's just your
imagination tick tick tick whatever it
is I'm sure you'll be fine there's
nothing dangerous about a weird sound
from time to time you don't have
anything to fear unless it suddenly goes
silent that's when you're really in
trouble when you know SCP 4975 is about
to strike to devour you alive wait stop
hold your breath don't make a single
peep do you hear it neither do I like
any other area in the United States the
State of Florida has a healthy share of
urban legends and local myths take for
example the legendary swamp ape the
Region's Bigfoot equivalent a hulking
creature said to run a muck in the
state's many swamps and Aquatic areas
identified by its strong repugnant odor
and deep guttural throat calls or the
ghosts of the St Augustine Lighthouse a
Grizzly tail revolving around two young
girls who drowned in the nearby sea
while their mother was working the
lighthouse too distracted to hear the
cries of her children as they were
swallowed by the current and returned to
the brine it's rumored that on Some
Nights the twins laughter and cries are
heard from the top of the lighthouse not
scary enough what about the Devil's
Chair a seeming ly ordinary bench
located in the town of cadaga that was
supposedly built by the Devil Himself
every night at midnight the man in red
returns to his bench and if you sit
beside him he'll whisper Wicked horrible
things into your ear leaving you forever
scarred and haunted by The Experience
just don't leave a drink behind when you
run off the bench in Terror though
another Legend says that any unopened
bottles left on the bench will
mysteriously be open open and drained by
the morning torturing damn souls for
eternity makes you a thirsty guy we
guess but to a seasoned viewer of SCP
explained urban legends and local
Oddities might seem a bit mundane in
comparison to the strange inexplicable
anomalies that the SCP Foundation
regularly researches and contains after
all the truth is almost always Stranger
Than Fiction and if an actual anomaly
gets picked up as an urban legend the
SCP Foundation is going to do everything
in their power to shut it down cover it
up and make the story a little more
digestible for the general public that
means relying on the same tired tropes
and cliches we've all heard before
cursed dolls Bigfoot like creatures
ghost hitchhikers we all know them and
as fun as they are the most popular
stories aren't always the most unique or
interesting and if you peer deeper
underneath the surface you can always
find kernels of truth in the most common
place of Legends for example what's
commonly referred to as Bigfoot or
Sasquatch is actually as CP 1000 a super
intelligent prehistoric race of ape
creatures known as The Children of the
Night who were slaughtered by early
humans and forced to hide from the world
in order to preserve their species a
cursed object or location the foundation
deals with those all the time and
stories of ghosts are as commonplace in
the anomalous world as they are in the
ordinary one but what about an anomaly
that utilizes urban legends to further
its own nefarious goals one that's
lifeblood is localized to a single area
today on SCP explained we're going to be
talking about SCP 3640 an anomaly that
capitalizes on the interest and Intrigue
those urban legends generate
specifically those in the State of
Florida we already talked about the
variety of weird and creepy stories the
St calls its own but what else is
Florida known for tourism retirement
communities beautiful summer weather
slightly crazy individuals making news
headlines for ridiculous reasons how
about Disney that's right the State of
Florida is known for Walt Disney World
the granddaddy of all theme parks that
brings in millions of tourist dollars
annually and the hub for some of the
most iconic characters and stories in
the world if you've ever been to Disney
World then you know about the costume
characters that roam the park silent
mascot costume Renditions of your
favorite TV and movie characters posing
for pictures and having fun with
children the park is practically
infested with them they seem inescapable
it's pretty understandable that some
people are unsettled by mascots they can
sometimes be downright creepy with those
unmoving expressions giant heads
unnatural movements and the faces of
familiar fictional characters in the
right context a mascot can be just as
scary as any horror movie monster or
urban legend could ever be here's a
situation for you you've just landed at
a Florida airport you're ready to go to
Disney World and enjoy a vacation after
you've been worked to exhaustion as a
junior researcher at the SCP Foundation
you want to get familiar with the state
but you're trying to cut down on your
phone usage after all you're on vacation
why not do things the oldfashioned way
and unplug from Electronics you spot a
brochure rack in the distance perfect a
paper hub for everything touristy in the
area among the hundreds of jet skiing
courses Beach information and many golf
pamphlets one brochure in particular
stands out to you maybe it's your
background in the anomalous but you just
can't help yourself from picking up a
booklet on Florida's urban legends
knowing what's behind the curtain
working for the SCP Foundation really
makes these types of things more amusing
you've seen how the sausage was made
and it's a lot more terrifying than
anything known to the general public
heck you know for a fact that the
organization you work for has more than
likely not covered up most of the actual
incidents that inspired these local
Legends nonetheless you pick up the
brochure interested in the self-guided
tour of Florida's paranormal hotspots
and you're impressed to find that this
booklet has it all everything from skunk
Apes to a cursed doll it's all in here
you chuckle and Tuck the pamphlet
underneath your arm but little do you
know you're about to experience
something more horrifying than any urban
legend could ever be you see if you paid
attention to your foundation briefings
before you left the state of Florida you
would know that any foundation Personnel
who encountered tourist brochure
pamphlets advertising self-guided
paranormal tours in Florida are to bring
said pamphlets to the foundation's
attention immediately mobile task force
lambda2 nicknamed Pest Control is primed
on demand for incidents related to these
brochures
why because they're a part of a
phenomenon categorized by the SCP
Foundation as SCP
3640 but what is SCP 3640 why is
something as innocuous and fun as a
paranormal travel brochure an object of
high interest for the SCP Foundation
well you someone who should have maybe
listened to the regional briefing
conference back at site 19 before you
left on your vacation are about to find
out after perusing your booklet and
ruminating over the numerous locations
at your disposal you decide to visit one
after you get settled into your hotel
after all you're about to experience a
week of family-friendly fun at the house
of mouse why not partake in a little
horror just to get the blood pumping a
bit of living life on the edge before
the scariest thing you have to deal with
is a $10 bottle of water and a 3-hour
waiting line to ride that giant golf
ball you drive all the way out to the
location the pamphlet specified a bridge
by the name of Sunshine Skyway located
right outside of Tampa Bay visiting the
bridge at night might also get you a
visit from a mysterious and beautiful
hitchhiker woman who stands on the side
of the bridge and attempts to flag down
cars if you happen to take her in she'll
begin to weep growing progressively
louder and louder in her screaming and
crying until you reach the other side of
the bridge and when the driver turns
back to ask her what's wrong the woman
will have vanished Without a Trace
sounds like a fun time right maybe you
can find her heck maybe she's single and
interested in an enthusiastic and kind
Junior researcher of the SCP Foundation
you would never contain her you promise
having to raise your voice over the
sound of her weeping and crying in the
backseat of your car or maybe not this
vacation time outside of the lab is
making you think some strange strange
stuff whatever the case is you want to
see a ghost girl so you make your way
over to the Sunshine Skyway at 11: at
night just like the pamphlet specified
the bridge is strangely empty especially
for what's usually a crowded stretch of
the road in fact now that you realize it
there's no one else here just you your
car the Black Knight sky and the sound
of your humming engine well up the road
you go looking for this supposed ghost
hitchhiker the Skyway is quite the drive
and the longer you ride the less safe
you feel but you're fine right it's a
very popular Bridge driven by thousands
of people every day and night it just so
happens to be completely empty at an
ordinary time of night and you can see
the dark outline of a figure in the
distance standing in the middle of the
road as you drive closer and closer you
start to make out the figure a bit more
a circular head a tall wide body and two
more circles on top of that round ball
head closer a little closer and wait is
that there's absolutely no way that's
who you think it is is that a Mickey
Mouse costume standing in the middle of
the road it apparently is and it seems
like it's not getting out of the way you
honk your horn but the overground rat
doesn't listen it's still standing there
unmoving you slow down you know what
Disney's legal team is capable of and
you are absolutely not going to jail for
running over Mickey Mouse so if he's not
moving out of the way you will instead
you try to maneuver around the
stationary mascot but suddenly out of
nowhere the thing leaps 15 ft into the
air and jumps onto your hood you scream
as the Mickey mascot skitters across the
roof of your car clawing and tearing at
the sunroof trying to get in you push
your foot on the gas as hard as you can
enough Force to propel Mickey from the
roof but it's not enough the mascot hits
the ground but immediately gets back up
and starts running after your car almost
instantaneously it catches up to your
car again and uses its strength to pry
off the door on the driver's side of the
car exposing you and causing you to lose
control of your veh vehicle you swerve
crashing into the side of the bridge and
banging your head off of the steering
wheel you never thought your life would
result in death by Mickey Mouse but the
rapidly approaching costume creature
seems to be saying otherwise the Mickey
creature bends down and uses both of its
gloved hands to grab you from your car
seat with enough Force to break the seat
belt and give you minor Whiplash from
being flung into the air so quickly this
is it you know it's over and you don't
even know what's going on on or why this
is happening you're just another victim
of something you don't understand like
the countless dead you spent your life
researching or so you think just when
you assume that it's all over a shot
rings out from across the bridge and you
see a salvo of bullets pepper Mickey
Mouse's back carefully missing you with
impressively accurate Precision Mickey
drops you banging your head on the
concrete and runs towards where the
bullets are coming from several armored
heavily armed soldiers appear from the
side of the bridge and circle the mouse
they fire again but it has little effect
on the mascot once again he lunches
forward knocking a soldier off his feet
the mascot dashes off into the distance
leaving over the side of the bridge
though no splash is heard in the water
below you don't see the mascot Landing
or even escaping it's like he was never
there in the first place but at least
it's gone now and you have these unknown
soldiers to thank you for your wait is
that an SCP Foundation logo oh no
they're Foundation task force operatives
before you're able able to fully regain
your senses you can already hear the
task force Captain telling his underling
to prep you for amnestics and an
interview the soldier approaches you and
you're thankfully able to muster out a
few Choice words namely wait wait wait
wait I'm with you guys I'm a junior
researcher the captain pauses and laughs
to
himself what are the odds after you're
processed and taken to the nearest
facility where your identity as a card
caring member of the SCP Foundation is
confirmed you're let in on what exactly
it was you just saw back there as it
turns out you had an encounter with SCP
3640 an anomaly centering around a set
of travel brochures that advertise
self-guided tours of all of Florida's
paranormal hotspots if someone reads the
brochure and goes to a location at a set
time just like you did they'll be prayed
upon by a mysterious predatory entity or
set of entities that resembles costumed
mascot characters owned by the Walt
Disney Company Mickey Donald Goofy the
task force Captain explains that they're
all there and they're all over the State
of Florida hundreds of mascots maybe
more they're fast dangerous and the
foundation knows remarkably little about
them including how they grow reproduce
or even consume their prey all of the
known hotspots advertised in the
pamphlet are routinely watched by
members of the past control mobile task
force where operatives are authorized to
neutralize SCP 3640 entities with lethal
Force which is how that task force was
able to thankfully show up at the right
moment and save your life SCP 3640 only
attack those who read the brochures and
haven't been seen being hostile or
hunting outside of the area specified by
the pamphlet after you recollect
yourself and thank them the captain
hands you a file briefing on SCP 3640
gives you a Stern warning and tells you
to familiarize yourself with it before
you leave the facility what a way to
start your vacation you think just when
you thought you were able to escape the
the daily horrors of working for the
foundation you stumble upon an anomaly
yourself but you undoubtedly have more
questions about SCP 3640 after all
anyone would after witnessing as weird
and strange an anomaly as that in the
wild you ask the captain why the
foundation hasn't captured an SCP 3640
instance especially if they're so common
in the Florida area he sits down sigh
and explains that the foundation did try
a while back it was a standard d-class
test held in the St John River the
location of a supposed river monster the
d-class Personnel was dropped off at the
riverbank and told to follow the
instructions in the pamphlet if they
spotted a mascot they were to shoot at
it with a tranquilizer gun after
dredging through the river for a few
minutes and being distracted by a neat
looking alligator the d-class eventually
came head-to-head with none other than
Donald Duck himself who emerged from the
river and immediately began moving
towards the d-class the d-class
naturally freaked out completely and ran
away from the scene but Donald was
simply too fast just when he thought he
was safe the Donald mascot emerged from
the shadows and knocked the camera and
radio off of the d-class head there were
sounds of a struggle but the d-class
never established contact again however
his subdermal tracking transmitters
continued to operate and before they
went offline completely they luckily
detected the location of the de class's
body it was just outside of the Epcot
amusement park engaged by the captain
story you ask him what happened next
surely the foundation launched an
assault on Epcot to figure out what
happened to the d-class right the
captain Grunts and tells you that the
rest is classified but you're not
satisfied you're refusing to move until
you figure out what happened to this
d-class the captain rolls his eyes and
perhaps feeling sorry for you decides to
tell you the rest of the story him and
his team were deployed just outside of
the Epcot Theme Park right next to a
one-story concrete Hut where the declass
is location was tracked they were
equipped with heavy arms a net launcher
and a flamethrower all perfect weapons
for subduing these deadly mascots while
Lambda 12 was typically used to hunting
anomalous bugs and pests they figured
that hunting down Donald Duck and Minnie
Mouse was more or less the same thing
when you squint really hard and pretend
that they have wings the task force
broke into the Hut revealing it to be a
maintenance shed with a mysterious trapo
in the middle of the floor underneath a
ladder led to a tunnel system similar to
the ones built underneath the Disney
parks that the employees used to get
around from park to park the team
spotted several dressing rooms and
storage rooms all empty and aoid of life
after some exploration the team followed
a low rumbling noise to a closed door
they slowly opened it revealing an
abandoned Boiler Room with a white
mascot costume at the foot of the boiler
curled up around an unknown object an
operative approached the costume and
poked it with a rifle identifying it as
an empty Daisy duck costume the team
examined it further and found a human
armb bone inside the suit discusting to
be sure but nothing the task force
hadn't seen before they turned over the
suit to examine the object it was curled
around discovering it to be a purple
plastic egg with an embryo inside
scattered across the floor were more
eggshells the squad gathered them as
well as the bones of the d-class in the
costume to bring it back to the facility
suddenly the task force heard noises in
the distance and assumed an attack
formation they noticed the floor of the
entrance they came in was now covered in
dark fluid and polyester stuffing the
trail of liquid exactly matched their
path of infiltration into the tunnel
after determining the situation to be
safe the squad carefully left the tunnel
the way they came bringing the costume
and the egg with them after several
weeks the egg hatched into a miniature
stuffed Donald Duck toy the foundation
dissected it discovering it to contain a
plastic endoskeleton and a rudiment
polyester stuffing muscular system
inside and that was everything the
captain had to say there was never any
other leads on the SCP 3640 anomaly just
strangeness and inexplicable inability
to capture or understand the mascots you
think the captain for not only saving
you but explaining what was going on
before you left the facility to go back
to your regular foundationless vacation
you took another glance at the document
the captain handed to you on the back
page was a chilling letter datting from
1979 written to Florida Governor Ruben
ascu by the Walt Disney Company it read
as follows the Walt Disney Company
thanks you for your cooperation in this
matter regarding the unlicensed Walt
Disney character operators please pass
along the following information
collected by the outstanding men and
women of the city of Orlando's Police
Department to the Florida National Guard
if a character is spotted call to get
its attention and then rapidly flash
your flashlights at the costume if it
does not flinch fire on site aim at the
head if possible else aim at the knees
to disable them and then finish them off
with head shot body shots have been
shown to lack Effectiveness deceased
characters are to be incinerated no
other means of disposal are advised we
are currently pursuing alternative legal
means of shutting down these unlicensed
operators and hope to achieve a
settlement within the end of the year
cordially yours the Walt Disney Company
October
1988 SCP Foundation agents sirel Novak
and Diana Fischer have been dispatched
to Austria's capital city Vienna to
investigate a series of mysterious
unexplained disappearances the
foundation was unsure if these events
were connected or even anomalous in
nature but they had reason to believe
that something was lurking beneath the
dark streets of Vienna a foundation
operative embedded in local law
enforcement informed the organization
that the authorities were panicking with
an emphasis on with holding information
about these disappearances from the
public and the media Novak and fiser
conducted a survey of the city observing
the streets at night and keeping a
watchful eye on those who they deemed at
risk it was the undesirables of society
that were disappearing in droves
unsupervised children vagrants the
homeless all those that were indisposed
vulnerable and otherwise at risk of
being forgotten by Society were
potential victims according to several
sources these these disappearances were
taking place near access points to the
city's Subterranean infrastructure sewer
holes access tunnels storm drains
anywhere that led to the underground was
a potential risk site after a few days
of standard exploration and information
gathering around Vienna Novak and fiser
moved on to interviews with law
enforcement and public officials using a
variety of cover stories they managed to
pry out A Deadly Secret from the mouth
of the police chief human remains had
been recovered near The Disappearance
sites the authorities opted to keep them
a secret from the public so as Not to
cause any Panic of a craze serial killer
on the loose or Inspire fears of
something even worse lurking in the
city's underground the agent seized the
three cavers and alerted the foundation
that their mission had been progressing
as expected the bodies were transported
to humanoid containment site 282 in Gaz
Austria where they were immediately
examined by Dr Felix gner who performed
an autopsy on the three corpses if the
foundation was unsure about anomalous
involvement before they were certain of
it now the bodies were in shambles
mutilated beyond belief and altered into
an almost unrecognizable State the mere
stench of them caused Personnel working
with them to rush to the bathroom and
even those that could typically keep
their lunch down had a difficult time
examining them Cav a the cause of death
was determined to be from exanguination
or the extreme loss of blood kav be was
Miss missing some important fleshy
components inside and out some of which
had been removed entirely the cause of
death was presumed to be traumatic
Cardiac Arrest the third corpse Cav SE
was barely a body instead it was a
collection of Bones and fluids the cause
of death because of the opaque
conditions the cadaver was found in was
unknown these Grizzly deaths were only
the start of the foundation's
containment of this anomaly and are far
from the worst this file has to offer
this is SCP explained and today we're
going to be looking at SCP
3288 a collection of entities otherwise
known as The Aristocrats Dr Gartner's
analysis of the cavers came to a single
conclusion a human could not do this in
fact he compared the deceased's injuries
and conditions with the bodies of
victims of hyena attacks all sustained
injuries weren't the result of a blunt
object sharpened blade or a firearm but
instead resulted from a combination of
teeth claws and raw physical strength
the bodies had abnormally large bite
marks approximately six times the size
of adult human teeth yet closer analysis
revealed that the indentations did in
fact coincide with human teeth whatever
did this possessed more than 60 teeth
unevenly distributed over six distinct
rows and required Jaws much larger than
those of ordinary humans there were
unique patterns among these markings
suggesting that it wasn't a single
entity that ravaged these Corp
but multiple there was no doubt about it
these deaths were anomalous in nature
the foundation issued a designation for
the entities responsible SCP 3288 and
deployed mobile task force Sigma 6 hell
singers a special unit trained to
capture deadly anomalies in the field to
bring SCP 3288 into Foundation custody
the operatives were tested with
patrolling the lepold district the area
where most of the disappearances had
occurred secrecy as usual was a top
priority and members of the task force
took Extra Care to conduct their
operations away from the public eye as
the purpose of this mission was to
contain the entities for further study
the operatives were also ordered to
refrain from lethal force and to Target
SCP 3288 with tracking darts to prevent
them from escaping the task force
divided up their assignments 12
operatives would Patrol the district and
search for any suspicious activity while
10 others would remain watch in position
positions with unrestricted views of
sewer holes and other underground access
areas for the first few hours things
were quiet but then two operatives
stationed near the danoob canal made a
report to the rest of the team someone
near the canal was screaming not loudly
but in a muffled faint way the
operatives took initiatives and ran off
to investigate the matter themselves
requesting backup at the same time
reinforcements arrived Less Than 3
minutes later but their teammates could
not be found moments later their bodies
were discovered by another operative
mangled beyond belief both operatives
were killed and alongside them was a
half consumed corpse of a local civilian
as well one operative body was recovered
from the canal while the other was found
after following a trail of blood and
fluids into an Alleyway but despite the
loss of life the mission was still
deemed a success before being mauled by
the SCP 3288 instance the task force
operative managed to shoot the entity
with a tracking bullet a piece of
technology U izing satellite location
which allowed the rest of the team to
follow the entity into the sewers the
tracking was working perfectly and the
entity was shown to be fleeing into
Vienna's sewer system until the signal
faded somewhere near the hoffberg a
palace constructed centuries ago that
was once host to the hapsburg Dynasty
and presently serves as the seed of
power for the president of Austria the
team was confused as the fading nature
of the signal suggested that the
tracking bullet had been brought into a
location far deeper than the vienes
sewers were believed to accommodate the
mission moved onward into the depths of
the sewers in pursuit of SCP
3288 the following day the task force
had assembled a strategy for mapping and
exploring the vienes sewer system
constructed in the mid 19th century
these sewers were part of a larger
network of subterranean tunnels that
include catacombs abandoned wine cellers
and underground Rivers without proper
planning and clear communication death
could be a very real Poss ability and
not even one caused by SCP 3288 the task
force was divided into four teams of
five three to investigate the sewers and
one to remain on standby by
triangulating the location of the
tracked instance the foundation was able
to pinpoint the general area they would
need to explore by blocking off certain
exits and surface access points they
hope to minimize the possibility of the
entities's Escape or exposure to the
public while the primary objective
remained containing an SCP 3288 instance
for scientific research lethal force was
authorized to be used in case of
emergencies the foundation valued the
lives of its trained soldiers and put
them above nearly anything still the
authorization of lethal Force spelled
impending doom for many experienced
Veterans of the task force they knew all
too well about what kind of entity they
were up against when the foundation
opted to skip the containment step and
prioritize getting out alive a team of
operatives reached their destination
safely but didn't discover anything of
significance during their Trek through
the sewers of Vienna at least not at
first after several hours of
Investigation they encountered human
skeletal remains while making their way
through was steep sewage one member of
the task force pointed out a loose brick
in the wall and then another did some
minutes later inspection of the area
found a number of loose fitting bricks
that were able to be removed with ease
as if they were put there to hide
something when the entryway was fully
Unearthed it revealed a previously
unseen chamber whose walls were engraved
with a house of hapsburgs coat of arms
operatives inside of the chamber
immediately knew what they were looking
at a family crypt of Royal bloodline
never uncovered before the Forgotten
atmosphere made them feel like they were
discovering a secret that they were
never supposed to know 24 sarcophagi
were found within the chamber and
historical records of the sewers and
surrounding area mention nothing about a
crypt beneath the palace multiple
statues were recovered from the chamber
as well depicting veiled women with
hushed Expressions holding a finger to
their lips almost as if to say that this
place was a royal secret and trespassing
had grave consequences get it grave
consequences
no okay moving on thought I would be
funny today the tombs themselves were
intricate decorated with ornate jewelry
and various expensive embellishments but
did not include placards markings or any
indication as to who was intuned within
when the operatives opened the ccop Sagi
they were disgusted the skeletal remains
of over 300 bodies all displaying severe
and likely fatal birth deformities the
team was at a loss what was the meaning
of this room the entrance had been
destroyed some time ago with stairs
shattered and buried among the Stone
near the other side of the row of tombs
was a vault door coated in bronze and
bearing the coat of arms of the
hapsburgs a seal written in Latin was
engraved beneath the coat translated it
read for purity of blood the task force
tried to pry the door open but it
wouldn't budge opening it would require
special equipment and after what they
had witnessed inside the sarcophagus
some members of the team were even
hesitant to continue trying the team was
ordered by the supervising team to hold
their location and await the arrival of
another team that would open the door
Foundation agents on the surface
organized a temporary evacuation of the
hoffberg building the team waited for
backup throughout the night they made
attempts to open the vault but to no
evail
once the surface had been properly
evacuated and an infiltration team
arrived inside the chamber to assist
with the vault door the gate was able to
be open using oxygen fuel cutting
torches over a period of 2 hours once
opened the team was met with an ominous
descending staircase leading to an
unknown dark location underneath the
palace an 8-man Squad heavily armed and
equipped with recording devices ventured
down the staircase radio Transmissions
from the squad grew increasingly faint
over time when they reached the
estimated 65 M Mark underground their
Communications arrays were barely
audible at the bottom of the stairwell
was an ornate foyer instead of decaying
gry stone walls and oceans of sewage
there were marble floors with felted
carpets and white painted walls and
ceilings this chamber was found to be
architecturally identical to a certain
wing of the hoffberg palace furthermore
the chamber was clearly built in the
18th century as many aesthetic choices
popular during during that era were
clearly present much like the Crypt
there were sculptures and statues but
this time there were also columns
paintings and tattered tapestries some
of the operatives admiring the beauty of
the room overlooked that on every piece
of art any in all depictions of the
human form were defaced and altered the
air was rancid with operatives
describing the odor as similar to rotten
meat and stale sweat the floor and walls
were discolored with what appeared to be
dried old blood regardless they moved
forward in between the space equivalent
of the hoffberg Imperial library was a
laboratory not found in the palace above
an operative collected numerous
documents relating to Alchemy biology
and the Occult as well as a journal of
transactions contracts and private
writings these documents were delivered
to above personnel and were later
translated by Foundation Personnel All
Along The Chamber were human remains
decomposing and strewn around the palace
suddenly a bell told at and the music of
a pipe organ began playing discordantly
for over 3 minutes operatives hid
themselves and deactivated their
flashlights some hiding behind the
curtains of a large Opera Hall and
others behind large instruments they
heard Footsteps in the distance minutes
later a group of figures emerged into
the palace Hall these entities the
foundation had classified as SCP 3288
were now fully visible their outfits
were typical of the 18th century
containing deep shades of red that
contrasted with their stark white skin
porcelain masquerade masks and powdered
wigs their bodies were monstrous with
arms dragging across the floor uneven
faces long fingers some possessing more
than 10 of and hunched backs a pair of
smaller instances entered behind the
horde of others and one blew a rusted
trumpet while the other held a banner
depicting the hapsburg crest the
trumpeteer began speaking but its words
were unintelligible and raw guttural
moan
they ran out of the way their stunted
legs causing them to trip across the
floor there were now over several
hundred SCP 3288 instances inside the
ballroom multiple operatives activated
silent distress calls requesting backup
to deal with the massive entities they
would have to contain these instances
bowed their heads and another mass of
footsteps were heard as a group of SCP
3288 instances carried a morbidly obese
instance a top of Throne it wore a cape
a red veil in place of a mask and a
crown too small for its head it was
evident that this was their leader a
large cauldron was placed before the
king a small instance climbed at top the
king's shoulder and lifted the entity's
veil to speak to it The Cauldron was
uncovered and the King lurched forward
grabbing the tub and pouring its
contents down its massive mouth some of
the king's disgusting meal spilled from
its mouth revealing a small human child
with severe deformities the CP 3288
instances roared an Applause and began
to feast all while the cacophony of
noise brought on by the various
instruments inside the ballroom raged on
an operative hiding behind a Harps
Accord was discovered by an SCP 3288
instance and quickly consumed by it in
The Feeding Frenzy the entities were
engaged in still barely alive before
being entirely digested by The Entity
the consumed task force operative
triggered an explosive device from
within the entity's stomach with a look
of immediate discomfort The Entity
suddenly exploded taking out several
other nearby 3288 instances with the
blast the entities were distraught and
while they were distracted the task
force leapt into action and rendered the
remaining SCP 3288 instances not killed
by the explosion unconscious using
devices loaded with a gas as Foundation
reinforcements arrived the surviving SCP
3288 entities were contained and moved
to site 282 including the massive King
whose body was transported using a
specialized crane after the removal of
all remaining entities the palace was
filled with cement and reburied with the
foundation making sure that no one would
ever Discover it again after the King
was contained Foundation Personnel were
shocked to discover that the entity
could speak in an interview with the
hulking monstrosity it revealed that its
name was maximilan the great a patriarch
of the house hapsburg the entity's
eyesight was severely damaged from
century of living underground and the
foundation was able to get the king to
comply by shining powerful lights in its
eyes The Entity was delusional believing
itself still to be inside the palace and
referring to the doctor as nothing more
than mere meat which it wanted to
consume when the doctor was able to
convince the king that he too was Noble
blood which the king believed due to his
unstable mental state The Entity uttered
a chilling statement we are of this same
Noble blood but some are more noble than
others our bloodline is pure untainted
by Outsiders we do not eat human we eat
peasants we eat
undesir we devour life undeserving of
life that is the nature of nobility what
else would be the point DNA testing
revealed that the King was in fact
descended from the House of hapsburgs as
all SCP 3288 instances were but what of
the journal entries discovered inside
the palace after translation the
foundation found that they contained the
writings of Leopold I a Holy Roman
Emperor and member of the Habsburg house
in the early
1700s his writings detailed his desire
to claim power over the royal family as
well as his fears of an increased number
of inbred deformed members of the
Habsburg house Leopold details meeting a
woman of Unknown Origin who promised him
that his family name could live forever
she taught him Arcane knowledge
involving experimentations of the flesh
small animals and eventually humans were
subject to Leopold's disgusting Unholy
experiments even his mystical teacher
became disgusted with what her tutelage
had wrought as payment she demanded that
Leopold cease his Reign deliver his land
and wealth to Common People and Destroy
his various deeds and titles Leopold
refused and had the woman burned at the
stake for witchcraft eventually
Leopold's experiments to make his
bloodline Perpetual resulted in the
creation of SCP
3288 years of inclusive family ties
mutated over one another generation
after generation until a horde of SCP
3288 living underneath the palace and
feasting on a diet of human meat were
created for years the surface hapsburgs
catered to SCP 3288s depraved and
disgusting needs providing them with a
slew of of humans to Feast on and a
lavish lifestyle akin to the one lived
by the nobility above one other document
revealed to the foundation that there
were multiple hives of SCP 3288 existing
throughout Europe most were discovered
and neutralized but the original writing
was heavily damaged by mold meaning that
there were some locations the foundation
was unable to uncover colonies of SCP
3288 instances buried underground
snatching humans without any care
mutating their own deformities and
living horribly unable to be stopped a
captured SCP 3288 instance in Germany
revealed that there was another entity
similar to the king in Authority by the
name of the empress it had this to say
to the foundation upon being contained
the meek will beget the strong the
doomed will beget The Chosen don't you
see the greedy the Devour the charitable
and the meress will ravage the peaceful
we will make the world as perfect as us
we will all be Aristocrats in the end
and our Dynasty will never die it was
July of 2004 and Bill Murray was
enjoying the peak of an extremely
successful career not only had the
iconic actors start in some of the most
beloved comedies of the 20th century
including Ghostbusters and Groundhog Day
he' voiced the main character of the
recently released live-action Garfield
movie it' been a financial success but
it was a critical flop not that this
bothered Bill he was happy with the
performance and the paycheck what he
wouldn't be quite as happy about was the
horrifying encounter he was about to
have with SCP
3166 on July 8th bill was enjoying a
cold drink on the porch of his luxurious
Beverly Hills Home the sky was beginning
to darken as the sun sun set in the west
it was a blissful evening his wife
Jennifer was inside watching TV nothing
seemed particularly out of the ordinary
until he noticed a quick flash of orange
in the distance it was almost too fast
to register this large orange shaped
darting past the corner of his eye for a
second he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escape Tiger but
it was gone too fast to really tell Bill
finished his drink and headed inside he
had enough for one night the next
morning he got up to read the paper and
found the Garfield movie getting
slaughtered by the critics one review
stated no one can accuse Garfield the
movie of infidelity to its source it
Faithfully conveys the vanality of Jim
Davis's cartoon another called it a film
without energy and without Spirit he put
the paper down and ate his breakfast a
few blows to the ego were worth it for
the paydays that came with big budget
family films just then his wife came to
him with a strange question were you
walking around downstairs in the middle
of the night no he hadn't he'd been
sleeping like a baby why did she ask
well Jennifer said I heard some rustling
downstairs last night it sounded like
something big he hadn't heard anything
though and told her it was probably just
Her Imagination he put it out of his
mind and continued about his day he
decided he would keep his eyes peeled
for that orange blur again though Bill
didn't see anything peculiar the rest of
the morning and went to a local cafe for
lunch he ordered a coffee and a cream
cheese B then made a quick trip to the
bathroom while his food was prepared
when Bill returned to his table though
there was something strange instead of a
bagel there was a large heaping of
lasagna on the table what was going on
this Cafe didn't even serve lasagna Bill
knew something was terribly wrong things
only got stranger when bill came home to
find a small tuft of orange fur snagged
on the frame of his front door and it
wasn't synthetic fur like you'd see on
plush toys or stuffed animals
no this was real animal fur maybe
someone was just goofing off or trying
to play some weird prank on him but it
didn't feel like it deep down Bill
Murray knew that he was in grave danger
whoever or whatever was behind this it
wanted to hurt him that night his worst
fears were realized Bill's wife had left
town for the week and he was headed to
the kitchen in the middle of the night
for a glass of water when he saw
something a huge figure moving up
against the glass door leading to his
backyard the thing was huge nearly 7 ft
tall with a bloated fur covered
misshapen body that was pressed up
against the door its fur was bright
garish orange a cartoon orange strangest
of all though was the sound it was
making it sounded like it was purring
Bill backed away from the door and then
ran back to his room to hide the whole
night he sat cowering as he heard
scratching against the walls like
something was trying to get in he was
terrified and too scared to do anything
even move finally as morning broke the
noises seemed to stop Bill had to do
something he couldn't let this nightmare
go on another night what if things got
worse what if that thing managed to get
inside he called the local police and
when they arrived he explained the
incredibly strange situation as best he
could he told them he was being stalked
by some kind of huge cat or at least
someone dressed like a huge cat also
there was lasagna involved the officers
interviewing him could barely contain
their laughter as he told them his story
a giant orange cat perhaps one of them
theorized he angered some kind of
obsessive Garfield fan through his
involvement in the liveaction movie
after all the original comic had been
running for years and had been extremely
popular who knows what kind of nut jobs
were obsessed with seeing only a
faithful adaptation of the source
material as the officers departed bill
was confident that they weren't taking
him seriously he couldn't rely on any of
them for protection thankfully from a
multi-decade movie career he had plenty
of disposable income and decided to hire
a private security team to protect him
while he looked into this mystery he had
two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month
they were armed and given the cryptic
orders to fire on anything orange
meanwhile Bill began to Fall Down A
Garfield rabbit hole he felt strangely
compelled to research all the Garfield
media he could find as though the answer
to his terrifying situation was somehow
hidden between the lines Bill explored
the entire backlog of thousands of comic
strips he read the books and interviews
with Jim Davis he watched the cartoons
and straight to DVD animated movies
ironically for a guy who'd recently
portrayed the lasagna loving orange cat
Bill had never felt quite so immersed in
the character before he found the
strange Pathos in the the routine of
Garfield and his friends one particular
comic really peaked his interest though
originally published in October of 1989
the comic began with Garfield being
woken up by a strange chill an almost
Eerie sensation the character observed
aloud that he didn't feel like he was in
his own home he explored his little home
further trying to find his owner JN or
his housemid and sometimes Nemesis ODI
but found nothing as Garfield remarked
on feeling alone a purple speech box
delivered the Sinister
message you have no idea how alone you
are
Garfield he then finds that his home
looks like it's been abandoned for years
the for sale sign outside is practically
ancient Garfield slowly comes to a
horrifying Revelation everyone really is
gone and his adventures and friends now
exist only in his imagination he's
trapped in a prison of his own creation
trying to Stave off his endless
loneliness
in denial about the reality of his
situation the comic ended with a quote
directly from Jim Davis himself saying
an imagination is a powerful tool it can
tint memories of the past shade
perceptions of the present or paint a
future so vivid that it can entice or
terrify all depending upon how we
conduct ourselves today as he read those
words Bill Murray felt a chill down his
spine why had he wanted to get involved
in the Garfield movie in the first place
what had he gotten himself into before
he could slip any deeper into his own
mind Bill heard a faint choked scream
downstairs he felt his breath catch in
his throat he was terrified but needed
to see what was happening he carefully
and quietly began to creep down the
stairs at the bottom he poked his head
around a corner and that's when he saw a
member of his security detail lying dead
on the floor his face was Blue from
asphixiation his mouth was stuffed with
lasagna
it looked like he had been force-fed to
death Bill wanted to scream but he
couldn't or maybe knew he shouldn't just
then he heard a soft meaty thumping
noise coming from the nearby living room
he didn't know why but he felt compelled
to approach as if by forces Beyond his
control he made his way to the living
room and when he'd got there he saw
where the noise was coming from Bill's
jaw dropped in pure horror there was the
other member of his security detail
lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure it was a grotesquely huge
creature wearing what looked to be a
kind of crude Garfield outfit made of
sewn together cat pelts it stank of
pasta and rotten meat in its giant Paw
It held a golden trophy which it was
using to pound the security guard's head
into mush while making quiet cat-like
purring noises the creature suddenly
stopped and looked up locking eyes with
Bill the fear of death came over him he
froze as the giant freakish Garfield
stepped over Donnie's corpse and began
to come towards him bill turned and ran
but Garfield was gaining on him before
he could make it to the front door the
creature knocked him over he was laid
out on the ground looking up at it as it
reached into its own body cavity and
began to pull out handfuls of lasagna he
was about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill's mouth when
suddenly a ding Was Heard and the
creature stopped
it looked up as if sniffing the air and
then suddenly turned and lumbered
towards the
kitchen Bill watched as the Garfield
monster entered the kitchen where
somehow there was a steaming hot fresh
lasagna sitting in the open oven the
creature had sensed the presence of
external lasagna and felt the compulsion
to integrate it into its body grabbing
fistfuls and shoving it into
itself just then a group of highly
trained SCP Foundation Personnel burst
into the room and subdued the creature
it had been an ambush the foundation had
been tipped off to the presence of the
creature by monitoring the local police
department dispatches and the report of
a 7ft tall comic book cat terrorizing a
Hollywood actor was definitely worth
looking into the monster that had almost
taken Bill Murray's life was SCP
3166 a deadly pataphysical being that
tends to manifest around people somehow
involved in the Garfield intellectual
property it appears whenever the public
perception of Garfield falls out of
favor and because Bill had starred in
the critically pan Garfield movie he was
currently at the very top of SCP 3166 is
Hit List thankfully he managed to
survive his terrifying ordeal and was
administered amnestics by Foundation
Personnel so that he could return to his
normal life this frightening and
mysterious creature has been around
since 1989 appearing after the
publication of The Haunting Garfield
comic that Bill had read that very night
it appeared in the office of United
media who were the Publishers of the
Garfield comic strip at the time and
began wrecking Havoc since then the
creatures manifestation has been a
constant threat whenever Garfield loses
its popularity or audience as a result
the foundation has spent years as the
funding source behind all Garfield media
and even planting hypnotic mimics into
the comic strips to ensure that there is
always a loyal fan base the fur is
indeed real organic cat fur albeit an
unnaturally orange color and instead of
organs the creature is filled with
lasagna worst of all though is that
testing has revealed that the meat in
the lasagna is genetically identical to
the Flesh of Garfield's Creator Jim
Davis how did this thing come into
existence perhaps it was Jim's sheer
force of imagination that dragged it
into being as he himself said an
imagination is a powerful tool all in
all it's lucky that Bill Murray was able
to survive his his encounter and return
to his normal life well as normal as
life can be for Bill Murray and if you
see Bill Murray don't bother asking him
about SCP
3166 the amnestics were quite effective
and just as he's fond of saying himself
no one will ever believe you an SCP
Foundation researcher sits at a table
inside of a standard containment cell
these are often dangerous places to be
especially when the SCP you're supposed
to be studying is one that you can't see
the researcher is taking notes unsure of
exactly what is going to happen next he
can hear the sounds of knives scraping
behind of Flesh sizzling and Searing
from high heat he braces himself as a
burst of heat hits the back of his head
as if a fireball has erupted an object
floats through the air and settles in
front of him on the table it's a plate
of food and it looks delicious it may
surprise you to learn that there is no
rule that the the SCP Foundation must
deal exclusively with violent and
vicious creatures not every SCP held in
containment shares the same malevolence
and contempt for Humanity as SCP
682 or the world-ending threat posed by
the likes of SCP
2317 some perhaps not many but some are
benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the SCP Foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with SCP 5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this quasi
humanoid meaning it appears to have some
vaguely human features is held in an
airtight cell that is regularly checked
by Foundation Personnel on a bi-weekly
basis SCP 5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with SCP 5031 is not
being eaten by it since though it
doesn't need need food it does still
hunt and consume anything it encounters
human or
otherwise avoiding being eaten is hard
enough with creatures that can actually
be seen But like so many other creatures
the foundation keeps contained SCP 531
has developed an almost perfect defense
mechanism which is when observed it will
literally cease to exist some might
choose to refer to this as a Quantum
lock however it is worth noting that
traces left by SCP 5031 still remain
observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by SCP 5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does
not naturally this makes both avoiding
the creature and capturing it using
cameras difficult however when SCP 550
31's existence ceases it still casts a
shadow from this researchers have been
able to determine several of the
creatures physical traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced that SCP 5031 levitates about
half a meter above ground level Sports
an abnormally small necklace head a top
and elongated torso approximately 1.9 M
long with three sets of spin Le lower
arms that Branch outwards using these
arms and its Loosely hanging body SCP
531 will lower itself to hunt any human
or animal that draws near to it and uses
the blade likee tail to cut up food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
SCP 531 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes are the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researcher Stanley
huxel appalled by the conditions that
the creature was being kep huxel took
over the role of HCL supervisor for SCP
5031 having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic towards the
creature listening to its screams from
inside its iron containment unit huxel
devised a series of of tests to
introduce SCP 55031 to various different
stimuli as a way to better understand
the creature and hopefully keep it
contained in a way that didn't seem to
cause so much suffering it's worth
remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes its mission to be cold not cruel
in performing their duties to protect
normality and many of the researchers
and staff are just as capable of having
empathy for creatures as you might for a
stray animal at a shelter the first of
huxtable's tests involved in stalling
speakers an SCP 5031 cell through which
a variety of different ambient and
popular pieces of music were played to
see if they had any effect on reducing
the creature's stress by judging SCP
5031 stress levels based on how much it
screamed when compared to normal huxel
was able to determine how to best use
music to calm the creature SCP 531
seemed to convey higher levels of stress
when listening to morning Forest deep
Grotto and seaside Paradise ambients as
well as the the best of late 60s British
rock band Jeth rotol however the best of
Mozart Ena kiss and Ben Folds produced
dramatically different results
decreasing SCP 531s apparent stress
following this test senior researcher
huxel compiled a playlist featuring SCP
531s favorite music over time the stress
reducing effects of Music on SCP 531
seemed to decrease but keeping the
playlist on shuffles seemed to keep the
creature consistently calmer than it had
been previous L the next test involved
introducing inanimate objects into SCP
5031 enclosure to monitor its reactions
and how its stress levels were affected
when a softball was thrown into the
enclosure SCP 531 immediately sliced the
ball in two with its tail in one swift
motion a similar result occurred when
researchers threw the creature a
basketball which was quickly punctured
and sliced open by SCP 5031 tail its
stress levels first seemed to diminish
when the creature was offered a bowling
ball which it rolled around the
enclosure and then later knocked it
against a second bowling ball however
when one of the balls chipped rendering
it unable to roll properly SCP 531
stress increased dramatically until a
replacement was offered researcher huxel
noted that SCP 531 seemed to possess a
similar level of motor skills to an
average human toddler with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to
match next when given the choice between
two food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure SCP 5031 seemed to gravitate
towards higher quality food most notably
favored cooked rotisserie chickens over
animal carcasses it even chose this
option over a live chicken using its
tail to cut its food into more
manageable bite-sized portions rather
than ripping its meat with its hands or
teeth like many of its fellow
scps researcher hustable recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though SCP 5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive providing the creature
with food of a better quality marginally
reduced its
stress senior researcher huxel next
attempted to test SCP 531s coexistence
with other living
subjects each time making sure that the
creature had been adequately fed to
avoid any unseemly
incidents first a life chicken was
introduced SCP 5031 rolled its bowling
ball at high speed towards the chicken
increasing both its and the chicken's
stress level and inadvertently killing
the chicken in the
process when a second chicken was
introduced SCP 5031 gently rolled a
basketball towards it but ceased any
further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball next
to be introduced into the enclosure was
a blindfolded d-class staff member who
was instructed to sit down and roll the
basketball towards SCP 55031 after doing
so for several minutes the creature
began to approach the d-class subject
who was instructed to remove their
blindfold to cease the creatur's
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
huxel had another class D engage in a
game of catch with SCP 5031 while facing
away from the
creature this test proceeded
successfully and Senior researcher huxel
remarked how SCP 531s motor skills were
improving albeit gradually and with some
gentle encouragement through hux's tests
the creature was learning the next test
focused on teaching SC p531 linguistic
symbols utilized LCD displays and
buttons connected to a food dispenser
One display showed an image of a rock
and the other an image of a rotisserie
chicken after some brief probing SCP 531
was quickly able to understand that
pressing the button under the correct
display would dispense a rotisserie
chicken for it to eat the creature was
later able to adapt when the following
day the screen displays and materials
dispensed were swapped and then later
set to swap at random intervals when
addition Rock dispensing stations were
introduced this time displaying the word
rock as opposed to an image SCP 5031 was
able to determine which station
dispensed chicken through a process of
elimination whenever the functions and
displays were swapped SCP 531 would find
whichever displayed the word chicken to
receive its food the Final Phase of this
test presented SCP 55031 with a single
station displaying the word chicken but
with a button that would remain inactive
unless the creature spelled out the same
same word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with after some
initial confusion and frustrations as to
why the button would not dispense food
when pressed SCP 5031 was able to
assemble the word correctly not only
activating the button and dispensing
food but proving to researcher Huxtable
that the creature was capable of
learning language Huxtable continued to
test the creature encouraging it to
spell words using lettered blocks as a
method of communicating by increasing
SCP P5 31's vocabulary and the amount of
human interaction it received senior
researcher huxel observed that SCP 531
was gradually learning to sing albeit
nonverbally as well as to juggle with
its six hands and was even communicating
its food preferences and Dish
pairings later another class D D 52125
was introduced to SCP 5 31's enclosure
to Aid in further testing through D
52125 instructions the teacher quickly
learned to draw using crayons and
created artworks depicting itself its
Newfound friend d521 125 researcher
Huxtable a cat and a rotisserie
chicken SCP 531s new creative side
didn't stop there though as the creature
quickly learned to play chopsticks in
only 2 days once a piano was introduced
into the enclosure SCP 55031 even
managed to start creating its own
original admittedly crude compositions
next a spice rack was placed inside the
creature's cell and D 52125 demonstrated
how to season meat this proved to be SCP
550 31's new favorite hobby as it spent
the next 3 days experimenting with
different combinations of foods and
spices using its letter blocks to
request more more more garlic powder
interestingly the creature only created
artwork or music when D 52125 was
present but seemed to thoroughly enjoy
its experimentation with food when left
alone following this development senior
researcher huxel devised a new test for
SCP 531 providing the creature with
cooking utensils and using D 52125 to
demonstrate 5031 was shown how to
prepare a variety of different dishes
from hamburgers and Tacos to Mongolian
beef steak clam chowder and profiterol
in addition to a small peanut allergy
this eighth test revealed SCP 5031 to be
a phenomenal chef possessing culinary
skills far beyond the average person the
creature quickly and enthusiastically
embraced its Newfound talents concocting
its very own brand new recipes with d
52125 even volunteering to be the first
to taste test 5031 dishes it was shortly
after this test that SCP 55031 spoke its
very first word and it should come as no
surprise that the word was salt
naturally senior researcher huxel was
very proud of of the progress the
creature had made with its development
the final test almost seemed to be what
the creature was born for over the
course of 2 months SCP 55031 was tasked
with creating a full three course meal
which would then be served to Foundation
staff for Thanksgiving SCP 55031 not
only Rose to the task but exceeded all
of researcher huxtable's expectations
creating a meal that even Gordon Ramy
would be hard pressed to find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric next came a
beautiful duck Ki glazed luxuriously
with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compost paired with
a site of butternut squash noi and
served on a bed of kale seasoned with
truffle salt the grand finale of the
Exquisite meal was a cassava pie
for dessert complimented with the finest
French vanilla ice cream and a maple
hazelnut syrup and SCP 5031 didn't stop
there the creature also debuted one of
its or original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
SCP 5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher huxel but the
entire Foundation staff as a fitting end
to the creature's taale huxel reported
that during the Thanksgiving banquet it
had created SCP 5031 stress levels
reduced enti entirely new Kinder
containment measures that would keep
5031 safer but also far more contented
were submitted for approval perhaps some
of you may find it refreshing to learn
that SCP 5031 isn't simply just another
malicious malevolent monster that the
foundation has to keep under lock and
key for the safety of the world instead
SCP 5031 is a gentle if a little
frightening at first creature that just
requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage and
aroundthe clock armg guards through
testing senior researchers Stanley huxel
and his fellow Foundation staff were not
only able to help the creature develop
but also found what makes it tick and
not just for the purposes of containing
it instead it is hoped that SCP 55031
creativity and flare for culinary and
musical masterpieces can continue to
thrive and grow under the proud watch of
researcher huxel you hear their
footsteps coming down the hall
or are those your own can you even tell
the difference you can tell they're
getting closer and you can feel the hate
the rage you turn shaking and finally
see them standing right in front of you
but in that moment you might as well be
looking into a mirror and who knows
perhaps you are you just don't seem to
remember having so many Reflections have
you ever heard the saying you are Your
Own Worst Enemy of course it isn't
usually meant literally
but what if it was what if you had to
fight a monster that was you all of your
flaws are reflected back at you your
strengths your weaknesses your deepest
fears with no way to escape except a
battle to the death either way you're
not making it out alive it's just a
matter of which version of you survives
but this isn't a thought experiment no
according to the findings of the SCP
Foundation it's very much a reality
there is a place where this nightmare
comes to life and it's known as scp1
1919 scp1 1919 is a hotel and converted
Mansion built in the early 20th century
from the outside it looks pretty much
like it did when it was first built and
it almost looks like a comfortable place
to stay if you ignore the Eastern side
of the building that has sunk partially
into the ground the inside however is a
different story where it's clear the
ravages of time have taken their toll
the floorboards and ceilings are rotting
collapsing in on themselves and the
rooms are filled with debris it's deadly
enough to explore the hotel for these
reasons alone but this is only the
beginning of the danger for person
inside in order to determine just how
dangerous it is for either one person or
group to enter the structure the SCP
Foundation planned a series of research
Expeditions into the abandoned building
led by Foundation scientist Dr lenowitz
the first first expedition seemed
relatively normal at least it did at the
start a 39-year-old Caucasian d-class
male known as D7 was sent into the
structure with a camera and a
communication system guided remotely by
Dr lietz or Dr Al and another operative
a former head of the MTF tow 11 youth
hostiles who is referred to in this file
only as t11 when he arrived at the
building D7 was unable to get inside
through the front door or Windows after
several minutes of trial and error he
was finally able to get in through the
Western entrance Dr L picked up a
strange high-pitched Whistling noise
upon d7s entrance into the building but
it quickly faded away and was
disregarded by t11 D7 discovered a torn
painting a portrait of a young woman
with red hair next to the portrait
shallow scratches could be seen in the
wall the floor and parts of the ceiling
suddenly D7 ducked into a hiding place
alarmed he and the other two operatives
listening to his audio feed could hear
heavy breathing and it didn't belong to
D7 Dr Al recommended that D7 evacuate
the building at this sign of another
entity inside but t11 overruled ordering
him to disregard that instruction and
continue his investigation D7 was told
to stay at a safe distance from whatever
was inside with him and attempt to
capture it on video D7 turned off his
flashlight in order to better hide but
t11 commanded that he turn it back on
what whatever was caught in the beam of
light was difficult for the camera to
see but it threw D7 into a panic and he
began to run in the opposite direction
when prompted to explain what he saw D7
simply said it was me D7 ran through the
dark panting with fear and exertion
unable to see where his feet were
Landing he tripped over something and
came crashing onto the ground dropping
the video camera this allowed the
observing officers to finally see what
D7 was so frightened by and it be became
clear just why D7 was so terrified a man
identical looking to D7 approached from
the end of the hallway making its way
towards the real D7 it was followed by
another man who also resembled D7 and
another all running toward the original
they all looked exactly like him with a
few notable differences they were
dressed in the same uniform with the
same build and the same features but
each had something slightly off about
him one was missing eyelids another had
malformed hands and the third had its
lips fused together into a fleshy Mass
beneath its nose Dr L moved to cut the
camera feed but t11 demanded that it be
kept running D7 couldn't be seen by the
camera but the microphone picked up the
sounds of Flesh and cloth being torn
along with pained Panic screams as the
duplicate set upon him after a moment
the screaming stopped 2 hours later the
camera was broken and the Expedition
brought to a troubling end this was the
the foundation's first Glimpse at the
creatures inside of SCP 1919 and it was
not pretty it did however allow them to
begin understanding the nature of the
building and what happens when a person
goes inside it appears that when a human
enters the hotel several humanoid
creatures manifest throughout the
building these creatures look like the
subject and are equipped with the same
clothing or items that the subject
brought inside with them though they are
nearly mirror images of the subject they
are always slightly warped in a variety
of ways these have included changes to
limb and digit length joint Mobility
sealed nostrils lengthened Jaws hanging
loose and Limp missing eyelids and lips
that are fused together these creatures
are highly aggressive towards the
structure of the building itself as well
as to the subject that they resemble
they do not however attack each other
they appear to operate with a hive mind
exhibiting swarm intelligence like that
of an ant colony once they have been
spawned by the entrance of a new person
they will not stop until said person
either escapes the building or is killed
after the unfortunate end to the
Expedition the foundation prepped for a
second trip inside this time three men
were sent in with Dr L's guidance known
as D3 D4 and D9 video cameras were sewn
into their clothes to leave their hands
free and help avoid some of the issues
that came up during the first expedition
this small team was sent in with the
orders to terminate the remaining copies
of D7 and further examine the hotel's
interior upon opening the door to the
building they were immediately attacked
by one of d7s copies which D9 was able
to quickly dispatch by firing his weapon
at its head next after a great deal of
reluctance the three men entered the
building where they spotted something
unusual inside Dr Al was horrified when
the camera feed revealed 17 discarded
video cameras spread across the floor
they didn't have much time to react to
this new discovery however because two
doubles one mirroring D7 and another
mirroring D9 emerged from the wall and
began to attack Dr Al ordered the team
to take shelter then called the team of
guards outside of the hotel's perimeter
they were ordered to begin an immediate
full perimeter lockdown preventing the
doubles from leaving the hotel D3 D4 and
D9 attempted to make their way to a safe
corner of the building but found
themselves met with a murderous double
at every turn at this point Dr Al began
to hear an unusual sound over the micro
phone feed a high-pitch whine like that
of a dentist drill the operatives on the
ground couldn't hear a thing but on Dr
L's end it was deafening as the team
proceeded deeper into the hotel they
became overcome with a strange feeling
of for boing Dr Al ordered them to turn
on their flashlights but they refused
and begged Dr L to keep quiet when
prompted to explain D9 said she can hear
you the operative stopped responding but
their camera feeds caught a faint
glowing white light coming from beneath
the the door the door opened and the
light flooded the camera making the
images it captured hard to decipher just
a few frames of a quick moving female
silhouette were captured before the
cameras cut to static the bodies of D3
D4 and D9 were never recovered nor were
there cameras a third expedition was
also sent into SCP 1919 but very little
is known about what occurred during it
the video transcript is highly
classified and only those present for
its events or proved to research SCP
1919 have access to it an update to the
SCP 1919 file following Expedition 3
though indicates that new information
was revealed about the hotel during the
Excursion according to the file update
there is some kind of being at the
center of the location which is causing
all of the other creatures the doubles
to appear the only information available
about this being is the use of the word
her in the official Foundation log about
CP 1919 this seems to match up with the
last moments of the operatives in
Expedition 2 when they told Dr L that
she can hear you and the few frames of a
female figure that were captured by
their cameras nothing else is known that
has been made available to anyone
outside a very select few only the
original report exists and all other
copies of it have been destroyed the
foundation has undertaken special
containment procedures to make sure that
none of the entities from inside the
hotel Escape whether they are the evil
twins spawned by humans entering the
building or the mysterious female being
at the center of the entire disturbing
phenomenon the foundation has classified
SCP 1919 as uclid and a 2 km radius must
be maintained around SCP 1919 with all
roads leading to the building are
blocked or diverted so that no vehicles
are able to reach it this perimeter is
guarded by a set of at least 40 armed
and armored guards at any given time as
it has been determined that the double
spawn by 1919 are equipped with whatever
the human they are copying has no one is
allowed to enter the hotel with body
armor or weapons of any kind anyone that
approaches the perimeter that is not a
part of an official Expedition team will
be immediately terminated no new
Expedition teams are allowed to enter
the building unless all doubles from the
previous Expedition have been
exterminated in the event that they
cannot be exterminated enough time must
elapse between Expeditions that the
previous doubles have starved to death
though they do not seem to feel hunger
the doubles do need to eat to survive
and will die when left alone for long
enough SCP 1919 has been sealed off from
the rest of the world so that no hapless
civilians can wander inside and find
themselves Torn to Pieces by warped
images of themselves but that Comfort
turns cold when you realize that the SCP
Foundation still does not understand
what causes these stubbles to spawn is
it scientific Supernatural or something
else no one can be certain even more
inexplicable is the entity at the center
of all of this an unknown female
presence capable of wrecking frightening
amounts of Violence by turning victims
own images against them what is the
purpose of these funh house mirror
nightmares who is she what is she and
what does she want currently the doubles
have shown no interest in leaving the
hotel except to attack Intruders and
thanks to that fact as well as the
reinforced perimeter outside these
copycats have not appeared outside of
the building itself but what happens if
they do Escape or if the entity that
controls them decides to make her home
elsewhere there is no telling what could
happen if this dark power is allowed to
move Beyond its current containment are
you prepared to fight a vision of
yourself Twisted almost beyond
recognition lunging after you with wide
bulbous eyes unnaturally long arms and a
distended jaw hanging down below its
neck better hope you never have to find
out the devil on your shoulder your
guardian angel these are expressions
that we've all heard countless times of
course they're not supposed to be taken
literally none of us have a Heavenly
Spirit looking over us and protecting us
from harm in the same way that nobody
really has a little red skinned imp
Whispering encouragement to commit
atrocious deeds in someone's ear their
metaphors Guardian Angel refers to any
instance of seemingly divine
intervention but it's more often a
coincidence that ends up benefiting a
person when they need it most and the
devil on your shoulder that's Temptation
the little voice in the back of your
head that sometimes eggs you on to do
something you know you shouldn't but
what if there was a being that was both
a demonic malicious creature that also
acted as a guardian for someone unable
to protect themselves is it even
possible for a being to be both angel
and devil and who out there could ever
qualify for such holy and hellish
protection ombre Rouge was once a fairly
normal place to live a small Louisiana
Town in one of the smallest of these 50
United States its name was derived from
the French language translating to Red
Shadow an ominous name for a Township
that was otherwise so uninteresting and
forgettable in fact if things had never
panned out the way they had Rouge would
have stayed that way just a place where
nothing interesting ever happened all of
that changed of course when the
disappearances started for anyone who
might be too young to remember them the
mid-2000s were a turbulent time the Iraq
war was in full swing and a nationwide
financial crisis was rapidly approaching
but in the midst of all this Global
chaos and instability the residents of
om Rouge were soon to be caught in the
THS of their very own shared t torment
at first like with most bad things it
started small one person went missing an
unfortunate occurrence but not exactly
unheard of sadly these things happen
especially when you live so close to the
swamp lands of Louisiana people wander
out into the marsh under the Searing
Heat Of The Sun only to suffer heat
stroke collapse and end up buried in the
dark dank mud never to be seen again few
of those living in the town took much
notice of the first appearance apart
from the missing person's relatives many
just Shrugged off the news as sad as it
was most of the town's folk were just
grateful it hadn't happened to any of
their own family or friends maybe it was
that ignorance that lack of vigilance or
reaction that meant a second resident
would also be reported missing not long
after the first but this time was
different unlike the previous
disappearance this one had an eyewitness
Clement Donovan known to locals as CLM
had spotted a passer by while taking out
bags of garbage this unassuming
pedestrian was the second disappearance
victim thinking little of the man who
just seemed to be walking home Clen went
back inside a split second later he
heard a scream from outside and rush
back to his dimly lit porch it was there
that CLM claimed he saw something
retreating towards the nearby Woods
however Clem's wild story of something
not quite human wasn't taken seriously
by local police
he even managed to snap a grainy photo
on his clamshell cell phone but back in
2005 phone cameras were nowhere near as
advanced as they are today most omre
Rouge locals wrote Clem off as a crazy
old man at best but worst it made him
look like someone who was trying to
exploit or make light of the
disappearances something that garnered
him a lot of dirty looks from his
neighbors that was until a number of
other residents started reporting they
had also witnessed a humanoid creature
creature it's hard to say if any of
these eyewitnesses were genuine and how
many were just people latching on to
Clem's story regardless the
disappearances hadn't stopped and it
didn't take long for an unknown
organization to roll into Al Rouge after
hearing the rumors of a creature
sighting a few residents even the local
sheriff's department thought these Shady
Figures were a division of forensic
Specialists here to Aid in the
investigations into the missing persons
the more conspiratorial folks living in
the Town had a different explanation
that the newcomers were a deep State
controlled top secret government group
there to assess the possibility that
there really was some kind of monster on
the loose not long after this group had
arrived in om Rouge the number of
residents going missing seemed to
dwindle on the 18th of December 2005
they packed up and left town giving no
explanation to the local police nobody
knew if this secretive Foundation had
actually uncovered the perpetrator
responsible for all the disappearances
if there even was any creature like the
rumors said but whatever had transpired
in that Louisiana swamp Town one thing
was clear the moment the foundation left
nobody else went missing from om Rouge
or at least not for over a decade before
then however little else of note
happened in om Rouge after the initial
Spate of missing persons cases this
apart from a car accident that took
place just under a year after the
various disappearances ended Ed a
heavily injured Man by the name of Simon
Hayes was taken to a local hospital
suffering from a severe concussion Simon
had been involved in a collision with a
car on the 11th of November 2006 the
doctors that examined him determined
that Simon had been left with short-term
retrograde amnesia a condition that
affected all his memories from prior to
the accident it was due to this that he
was unable to recall events that
occurred in the years before he'
sustained his injuries now what is it
that makes a random if unfortunate car
accident victim so significant well
Simon Hayes actually became the first
person in ombre Rouge to be declared
missing in almost a decade in 2016 10
years after his accident at 11 after the
original slew of disappearances Simon
vanished when returning to his hometown
in Louisiana to visit his family
naturally Simon Hayes wouldn't be the
last familiar face to return to the town
a repetition of such similar and strange
occurrences as before also brought the
mysterious Foundation rolling back in
little did the town's folk know in the
year that had followed the group's
original Exodus from om Rouge they had
lost something on the exact same day
Simon suffered his accident whatever it
was the foundation had left town with
had managed to escape perhaps this was a
purely coincidental occurrence but what
if it wasn't after all road traffic
collisions take place all the time all
over the world but an accident happening
in a town with a history of people going
missing on the exact same day that this
thing escaped captivity maybe there was
a link between the two events at the
very least the foundation seemed to
think so some of the more estud people
living in the swampside town noticed
black Armored Transport vehicles moving
into their neighborhoods men in body
armor locking down the hole of Al Rouge
these didn't seem like local police they
weren't even the National Guard although
they were certainly heavily armed enough
to cause concern this unit of specially
trained operatives quickly took control
of the entire Township their authority
never questioned by the sheriff's
department the place was small enough
isolated by surrounding swamps and
Marshland it was easy for mobile task
force Epsilon 6 to get away with an
operation like this before the people of
ombre Rouge had time to argue the task
force had already begun their
investigation the newest series of
disappearances had started in 2016 with
Simon Hayes mysteriously Vanishing and
had continued 2 years later in 2018 just
like the first bait back in 2005 there
were sporadic and unconfirmed eyewitness
accounts of a creature shaped like a
human but considerably taller almost 2 m
in height most Witnesses reported only
ever seeing this local Boogeyman at
nighttime making it much harder to see
in detail although a few seemed to State
its skin was deep red unlike any natural
human skin tone while before residents
of the Louisiana swamp Town had brushed
off stories like this as nothing more
than rumors and urban legends the
foundation seemed pretty receptive to
the idea of some kind of monster on the
loose in the Marshland and after all
they had good reason to believe such an
outlandish story because it was the same
creature that had already escaped from
them in 2006 continuing their
investigation into the link between
Simon Hayes and this creature mobile
task force Epsilon 6 also known by the
code name the village idiots arrived at
Hay's place of residence kicking the
door down breaching the house they began
a room byro sweep looking for any clues
that would explain why the monster they'
captured escaped on the same day as
Simon's accident one of the MTF
operatives uncovered something an
envelope stashed in the home Simon had
grown up in he opened it cautiously a
collection of papers that were contained
inside came spilling out there were a
series of simple drawings on paper that
seemed to be more than a few years old
the crudeness of the hand scalled
pictures and age of the paper seemed to
imply that they had been created by a
child a number of the drawings depicted
the same thing a creature just
like the one the town's folk had
reported seeing with them was a note
written by Simon's mother which read
found these old drawings of yours
thought you might like to see them again
welcome home there was a link and clear
maybe tangental connection but one that
was growing the more information the
foundation uncovered whatever this being
was a very young Simon Hayes had seen it
while growing up in om Rouge due to the
short-term retrograde amnesia that he'd
sustained after his accident he wouldn't
have remembered it but perhaps this
thing remembered him did that mean the
pair of them might be linked somehow not
just by coincidence but some kind of
connection that allowed the creature to
escape es its captivity on the exact day
Simon had his car accident a connection
that had drawn Hayes back home to om
Rouge or drawn the Beast to Simon to
kidnap him moving fast MTF Epsilon 6
began to rapidly sweep the remainder of
the Town searching for any further signs
that would lead them to the whereabouts
of either Simon Hayes or this elusive
Crimson skinned Boogeyman they
interviewed residents and chased cold
leads before eventually backing their
target into a corner the foundation MTF
operatives mapped the location of every
eyewitness report of the creature using
that information to track it back to a
possible point of origin it was a barn
left abandoned practically falling apart
as it stood in a state of disrepair just
outside the small Louisiana Town under
the cover of Darkness the task force
approached the wooden structure weapons
locked and loaded keeping them trained
on the barn cautiously moving closer
remaining on high alert the squad
activated their night vision there was a
low almost undetectable sound of
movement coming from within the barn
slowly the mtfs leader pushed open the
wooden door and peaked inside it was
there he saw what they had been looking
for the thing that had escaped the
foundation over 10 years before SCP
3631 a man and his monster the Beast was
just over 6 ft tall it skin a bloody
shade of crimson just as some of the
eyewitnesses had described it sported a
pair of of arms and bipedal legs giving
it a humanoid shape however that was
exactly where its likeness to human
beings ended the creature later
designated as SCP 36 31-1 lacked ears
eyes or a nose only a wide gaping ma of
sharp teeth its face was covered in
holes that twitched and puckered like
smaller miniature mouths in actuality it
used these orifices for various senses
it smelled saw and detected sound com
through the holes in its otherwise
mostly featureless face as the members
of MTF Epsilon 6 enter the barn
stealthily making sure not to alert SCP
36311 they cited something else someone
else was in the barn with it a man not a
dead victim or another monster like SCP
36 31-1 but an actual living breathing
human man MTF Epsilon 6's Commander gave
his Squad the signal to engage hearing
the sounds of weapons cocking around it
the creature turned and snarled crawling
on all fours like an animalistic
Predator at first it reared back it
wasn't until one member of the task
force approached that SCP 36 31-1
retaliated attacking the foundation
operatives in a frenzy following a
prolonged and bloody exchange MTF
Epsilon 6 managed to subdue the creature
and were able to once again return it to
Foundation captivity but this time
unlike back in 2005 they had SCP 36 31-2
as well as the red monster was prepped
for transport a survivor of the task
force noticed something an ID perhaps a
driver's license on the man's person the
Epsilon 6 operative picked the cart up
wiping away smears of blood with a glove
finger enough to reveal a single
familiar name printed on it Simon Hayes
before long just like last time the
foundation rolled back out of ombre
Rouge leaving the Louisiana towns folk
none the Wis about what had happened
there little did they know the Red
Shadow hanging over their home had been
lifted but it had come at the cost of a
number of disappearances that would
remain unsolved people who would never
be found families forced to go on
without Ever Getting answers when he was
returned to the foundation's labs SCP
36312 was sent for extensive examination
given the severity of the invasive organ
transplants he'd undergone it was
impossible to tell if he was in fact
Simon the creature had been regularly
replacing the man's internal organs on a
monthly basis whenever they showed signs
of Decay or failing somehow despite the
high risk of blood loss and infection
posed by this crude form of surgery the
subject had remained alive but he was
unable to speak conscious but showing
very limited responses to stimuli nobody
knows why the carnivorous nocturnal
monster SCP 36 31-1 took this man
captive in the same vein it is unclear
why the creature felt such a need to
protect him going to such lengths as
hunting for replacement organs from
unwilling donors perhaps in a Grizzly
Twisted way SCP 36 31-1 was this man's
guardian angel or maybe more a devil on
his shoulder I wonder is it really
possible for something to be both if
there's anything that recent years have
sadly taught us it's that diseases are
an Insidious and for itable enemy that
can take you by surprise whether it's
bacterial a virus a fungal infection or
even an unfortunate genetic mutation
like cancer Alzheimer's or multiple
sclerosis sometimes dealing with a
dangerous pathogen could leave you
praying for a runin with SCP 682 after
all at least getting devoured by a giant
evil reptile is a quick death but take a
page out of the SCP Foundation book
Sometimes the best response to an
imminent threat is containment and
research one of the first rules of
combat is to know your enemy it may seem
like a tall order to have to write the
book on dangerous diseases but
thankfully that book has already been
written it's SCP
1025 the Encyclopedia of common diseases
this handy reader friendly volume will
tell you everything you need to know
about all the common maladies you may
find yourself facing and a whole lot
more from the sniffles to lung cancer
from a cold sore to necrotizing
fasciitis you may be thinking why would
I need some dusty old book to tell me
about diseases I can always just go to
WebMD but you don't want that you know
what the internet is like they'll just
tell you you're sick and you don't want
them putting silly ideas in your head
like that how about you open up to a
random page and we'll take a look there
see the common cold classic let's see
the description the common cold is a
virus that affects the upper respiratory
tract it's duration is typically a
maximum of 2 weeks and its primary
symptoms include headaches muscle aches
a cough a runny nose raised temperature
pressure in the ears or face and loss of
taste or smell see simple
straightforward and objective exactly
what you need did you just cough H
that's strange H and come to think of it
your nose is looking a little red do you
need a tissue or perhaps a throat loss
your voice seems a little horse perhaps
you ought to take a break and lay down
down you really don't look so good seems
like the common cold to us thankfully
you shouldn't have to worry about it for
more than 2 weeks oh and that reminds me
there is a certain anomalous effect to
the Encyclopedia of common diseases
whenever you read about a pathogen in
the encyclopedia of common diseases you
catch it manifesting even its most
severe symptoms in an extremely brief
period of time of course this isn't that
much of a problem if you just read the
article about having a sore Thro throat
or a stomach bug but what if you read
the page for Ebola suddenly you're half
dead and bleeding from the eyes or the
Bubonic plague or a disease that
Humanity has never even faced before and
what if worst of all the people who
catch the diseases from this book
continue to be contagious to others it
could be the basis for a world
destroying biological weapon and at the
very least a Bonafide ker class anomaly
when the SCP Foundation got their hands
on this little hard cover anomalous
nightmare the researchers handling this
thing realized it needed to be kept
under lock and key a new provisional
site was created just to contain and
research it without the risk of its
anomalous effect starting an Unstoppable
Global pandemic the base was an isolated
underground bunker containing an even
more high security containment unit to
store the book itself a vault surrounded
by at least 10 armed guards at any given
time rotated twice weekly and checked
for any infectious agents there was even
a powerful thermite bomb stored beneath
the Vault set to go off and annihilate
the entire chamber if the plausible risk
of a Containment Breach was detected it
may seem insane to put in this many
security fail saves for a simple
anomalous book but the SCP Foundation
has dealt with dangerous books before
take SCP 140 also known as an incomplete
Chronicle this dangerous historical
volume Chronicles the living history of
the davit an extinct culture of sadistic
Sorcerers closely tied to the Mythos of
the Scarlet King whenever ink or blood
is brought into the presence of this
book it absorbs the material expanding
the dite history and bringing their
terrifying rule ever closer to the
modern day or take SCP 3512 the more you
know a pickup artist's Bible a deadly
instruction manual made by a
mind-controlling group of interests
known as the fifths this book gave its
Sinister practitioners the tools to
control the minds of their potential
romantic partners often leading to their
deaths well it may not be quite as
apocalyptic as SCP 1025 or SCP 140 the
fact that there are so many in
circulation still makes it a dangerous
threat point is a book can be a
dangerous thing especially if its Pages
have the potential to unlock deadly
diseases like SCP
1025 as you can expect with an
infectious Kass anomaly of this
magnitude procedures around this one
were rigorous the S staff was a Skeleton
Crew observing strict quarantine
procedures to prevent any potential
infection from leaking out into the
wider World Research into the history of
the book was inconclusive despite a bevy
of foundation resources being poured
into finding any worthwhile leads on the
author or publisher of the book nothing
it was an absolute mystery who or what
had put this XK Class end of the world
scenario waiting to happen here on Earth
but now it was the job of these Intrepid
researchers to discover the full extent
of its potential dangers 27 d-class
subjects were allocated to the base for
testing by the time the process was over
none of these unlucky prisoners would
remain alive the test started much like
this video the researchers forced a
d-class to read the section on the
common cold within 2 hours the subject
began coughing upon being asked they
also reported feeling physically achy
though they attributed the AEG to
sleeping on an uncomfortable d-class cot
every night the researchers were
concerned already the incubation period
for the common cold meaning the period a
person is infected before showing active
symptoms can be as long as 3 days 2
hours is unprecedented next to declass
was told to read the section on
Chickenpox a common childhood malady
that can be considerably more dangerous
in adulthood within an hour of being
exposed the d-class repeatedly scratched
no less than five points on her body
repeatedly while she claimed that this
was because of the Itchy d-class
jumpsuits it was is too eerily close to
a symptom of chickenpox to be ignored
the medical history of this d-class also
showed that she'd suffered chickenpox in
childhood suggesting that SCP 1025
infections have the power to override
previous immunities next things got a
little more serious they tested the
section on lung cancer on a d-class with
no family history of lung conditions not
long after the researchers noted that
the d-class coughed an unusual number of
times not only that they picked up
irregularities in the DCL class's
breathing that appeared to be
characteristic of lung cancer while the
d-class did not report any feelings of
chest pain or discomfort the researchers
had him terminated and dissected no
tumors were found a researcher noted
that they didn't wait long enough for
proper tumor manifestation they knew
they heard that d-class coughing the
researchers were so concerned by the
results of the previous test they
repeated it exactly with another d-class
who they then observed over a period of
7 days to track tumor manifestation
researchers made a note of an unusual
amount of coughing and wheezing from the
subject over this period of time the
d-class was then terminated and
dissected but surprise surprise no
tumors researchers began to consider the
frightening possibility that signs of
SCP 1025 induced illnesses disappear
after the victims die meaning that a
pandemic started by SCP 1025 would be
impossible to properly track and respond
to things were only getting scarier and
scarier for the SCP 1025 researchers
sequestered away in that isolated
Foundation bunker researchers continued
to delve further into the lung cancer
Rabbit Hole this time however they
didn't wait for the subject to die
before looking at their insides they
instead performed a Viv section on the
subject only to find that despite the
victim still being alive and displaying
some of the key symptoms of lung cancer
there were no tumors what could this
mean these diseases weren't behaving
like any of their non-anomalous
counterparts what other differences
could we be dealing with here infectious
lung cancer and what if there are more
books out there like time bombs just
waiting to go off the test continued
getting more isolated and more intense
in the end the SCP 1025 site was staffed
by only three researchers and two agents
acting as guards DCL classes were sent
in one by one to minimize r requirements
it seemed that they could have been
dealing with one of the most dangerous
anomalies of all time even working with
it could be a trigger for the apocalypse
if the proper containment and quarantine
procedures weren't observed things got
so out of hand that a d-class without an
appendix was told to read the section on
appendicitis and researchers still
observed him exhibiting symptoms of the
condition he was vivisected and while
the appendix was still not present the
organs in the area where the appendix
would have been SE R than usual when
would this nightmare end well it would
actually end much sooner than anyone
involved would anticipate despite never
even reading SCP 1025 himself a
researcher developed a strange
persistent cough and was quarantined in
a containment chamber by his concerned
colleagues on the seventh day of his
containment he seemed to be slightly
taller than before a symptom of SCP
016 a deadly anomalous bloodborne
pathogen that multiplies Wild ly and
rewrites the genetic structure of its
host if placed into a high stress
situation this led to a number of
terrifying Revelations not only did the
book have the potential to inflict a
number of anomalous diseases but it
could also potentially do so by pure
proximity even if you don't actually
read it what other anomalous diseases
could be on the table now what about SCP
00008 a terrifying Pyon with both 100%
virality And 100% lethality or SCP 742 a
retrovirus that slowly but surely
transforms its victims into
cannibalistic monsters or even the
horrifying SCP 217 the disease that
slowly converts your entire body into a
mechanical nightmare there would be no
limit to the horrors SCP 1025 could
unleash on the world if it ever got out
they needed to keep this thing locked up
at any cost that's when the infected
researcher escaped and all Hell broke
loose the isolated facility went dark
for 72 hours after not being able to get
into contact with any other Foundation
bases during that time a recovery team
was sent to investigate the Mystery One
agent and one researcher were found in
the observation Booth wearing biological
containment suits another agent was
found crawling through the air duct with
his handgun drawn a crazed look in his
eye an additional researcher had locked
himself in the barracks with a homemade
flamethrower paranoid about about
infection and the final agent was found
dead in a storage locker with some empty
bottles and ration packages after having
given the door an airtight seal to
prevent infection then dying of
Suffocation inside the 05 Council
shuttered the entire investigation SCP
1025 was downgraded from ker to Safe
class then placed in a storage locker
the whole thing was considered a wash we
know what you're probably wondering why
if this anomaly was so incred dangerous
why on Earth would the 05 Council and
the rest of the foundation be dealing
with it so casually well that's simple
the initial batch of researchers had
grievously misjudged the actual
anomalous effect of SCP
1025 it doesn't give diseases to those
who read its text instead it induces a
form of hypochondria by proxy to those
around the reader in other words while
SCP 1025 has no effect on the reader it
makes everyone around them merely
believe believe that they've come down
with a terrible illness the few members
of Staff in that isolated site had been
killing and dissecting DCL classes for
no reason in effect they had all
effectively gone mad due to the
anomalous effects of SCP 1025 and the
paranoia induced by pressure and
isolation much like your average
hypochondriac they warped the data to
fit the worst possible outcome rather
than the most mundane and likely as an
old medical expression goes when you see
hoofprints think horses not zebras the
entire thing had been a terrifying waste
of time money and human life so perhaps
in the end the Encyclopedia of common
diseases is a lot more like WebMD than
we thought it's not nearly as useful as
getting a consultation with an actual
doctor and of course it's liable to put
some very strange ideas in your head
happy birthday it's your day to enjoy
however you you want with lots of gifts
and sweets and look a little friend is
here to help you celebrate it's the
birthday monkey and he has a song to
sing dating back to the 1940s SCP 983 is
one of the most harmless looking objects
in the SCP foundation's possession it's
an old-fashioned mechanical monkey a
common windup toy from the old days it's
dressed in the sharp little vest and
holds a tiny bell and striking rod for
making music it seems to be a simple toy
the kind that would annoy a tired parent
as it plays its Little tune over and
over but nothing more but this is no
ordinary windup toy SCP 983 is capable
of sounds and even speech that doesn't
seem to match up with its design and an
investigation reveals it doesn't have
any signs as to how it was constructed
no screws seams or markings that would
be common on a toy and no voice box or
other mechanical feature that would
allow for speech but despite these
Oddities it seems to be a normal toy
that can be handled safely and played
with on every day but one that is
because SCP 983 has a second purpose and
on one special day it has a gift for its
Handler it can be a gift of Joy or a
gift of Terror nicknamed The Birthday
monkey SC SCP 983 activates when it is
handled by someone within the 24-hour
period of their birthday it seems to be
able to tell when this period of time
happens automatically and as soon as it
becomes aware a series of surprises
begin to surface for the lucky or
unlucky Handler it starts with a little
leap as soon as SCP 983 becomes aware of
the birthday boy or girl it'll do a
Charming little backflip it'll then lift
its Bell and start singing the same song
a ring a ding ding it's your birthday to
this day the foundation has not been
able to figure out exactly where this
voice comes from and it follows this by
ringing its Bell the tone of the Bell
varies widely in ways that the
instrument should not be able to create
ranging from low tones to painfully high
pitch tones and that's where the horror
Begins the birthday monkey doesn't just
want to sing a song it wants to play a
game the song will repeat every 3 to 4
seconds marked by rings of the bell and
for every Ring Of The Bell the birthday
boy or girl will age a year continuing
until they die of old age or win the
game but how does one win the game
before it's too late no one is sure but
studies of this strange toy in action
indicate that it involves singing along
and timing it correctly it's probably a
little hard to do that while aging to
death in seconds but no one said scps
play fair but in the event that someone
actually does manage to survive the
birthday monkeyy game it has a prize for
them when the singal is complete SCP 983
will let out an enthusiastic shout of
birthday ring its Bell and drop a single
Gumdrop from its Bell but which Gumdrop
depends on just how well the birthday
victim did a perfect singalong will
result in a clear candy that seems to
Glow if it's a little less than perfect
the candy won't glow but but it'll work
the same and both candies have a very
valuable property when eaten the candy
will immediately reverse any Age Loss
during the game but does the Perfect
Score give another prize studies of the
rare glowing candy led the foundation to
believe that it may also provide a bonus
effect making the person who eats it
younger and giving them a longer
lifespan or Better Health but this is
largely guesswork because the candy is
produced so rarely and the effects would
only become clear after years or Decades
of study but not all candies are to be
eaten many candies of different
appearance and quality have been
produced all can be eaten safely except
the black ones which represent a failed
singal the effects of this candy were
discovered the hard way because the
first time SCP 983 was activated it was
activated in the wild before the
foundation had secured it and everyone
knows knows that an SCP in the wild can
be a terrible thing it was at a local
flea market when the buyer noticed the
Sharp Dressed little monkey the buyer
having a friend who loved monkeys
thought this would be a perfect gift the
seller was not as enthusiastic and
warned the buyer that it shouldn't be
handled or even seen by anyone on their
birthday but even the seller didn't
really believe this saying that it might
have just been an old legend that had
been passed down for years it didn't
dissuade the buyer and off the monkey
went to its new home SCP 983 was
activated at an office party where the
monkey was presented as a gift the guest
of honor loved it at first until it
started singing the staff noticed that
as the monkey kept singing their
cooworker became more and more upset the
monkey kept singing and he started to
search for a way to turn it off but
there was no button or any other way to
deactivate it and that's when the
co-workers noticed something disturbing
the honory seemed to be getting weaker
and weaker and there were even streaks
of gray appearing in his hair his skin
was getting more wrinkled and weathered
soon his hair was entirely gray and he
simply returned the monkey to where it
was as it continued to sing he seemed to
give up begged for someone to turn it
off and waited to expire by the time the
foundation arrived on the scene it was
already too late there was nothing left
of the birthday boy but a desiccated
skeletal corpse the monkey had been able
to sing at least 30 more verses and no
one had truly understood what was going
on they reacted with confusion and
inaction unable to contain the monkey's
Dangerous Game even the foundation
didn't understand SCP 983 at first so
they let the object continue singing
until the body degraded into a simple
skeleton that's when the monkey
exclaimed its finishing phrase and
released a single BL black Gumdrop while
no one ate the Gumdrop the foundation
observed that it seemed to hypnotize
people around it as if it was compelling
them to do something what is lurking
within the black gumdrops and do they
want to be consumed the birthday monkey
was taken into SCP custody and it became
clear that it was harmless to everyone
for 364 days of the year the foundation
wanted to understand more about this odd
toy so they fell back on their best best
resource for testing d-class Personnel
who got the chance to show off their
singing skills with much higher Stakes
than your average round of karaoke most
of the tests were routine with
controlled activation showing how to
deactivate the monkey or providing
upclose studies of its devastating
effects but one test hinted that this
specimen could be more dangerous than
thought few people volunteer for testing
duty at the SCP Foundation but that
wasn't the case for one now classified
subject her birthday was approaching and
she surprisingly volunteered for the
test that could only be done on your
birthday she had an oddly upbeat
attitude and seemed oddly excited about
her birthday the test was approved and
she was given limited information she
was given the monkey as a wrapped gift
told it would sing and encouraged to
sing along for a video but her reaction
indicated she might know more than
expected as soon as the gift was was
unwrapped the SCP began singing after
missing the first verse the subject
picked up the words and started to sing
along not just competently but perfectly
and
enthusiastically soon enough she started
aging rapidly but didn't seem distressed
by this at all she maintained her high
level of enthusiasm even as the monkey
sang for over 40 verses and aged her
over 40 years she seemed unaware of
these drastic changes had never missed a
beat of the song Until the monkey issued
its finishing exclamation and now it was
time for her prize the Gumdrop that fell
from the Bell was a new one completely
white and almost shockingly bright it
glowed and the subject was immediately
Enchanted by it even the attending
scientists and staff couldn't help but
comment on how impressive it was the
subject was allowed to consume it to see
its effects and was monitored for an
hour afterward when nothing unusual
happened bes besides the reversal of the
Aging the subject was excused to return
to her quarters and that's when things
took a shocking turn in an effect never
seen before the subject suddenly
exploded with a brilliant burst of white
light whatever this light was it was
strong enough to knock out all the
cameras in the vicinity everyone in her
presence was temporarily blinded with it
taking 5 minutes for their eyesight to
return no long-term ill effects were
shown but the staff that entered the
room after the blast noticed that the
odd glow remained in the room and that
wasn't the only odd thing the test
subject was nowhere to be found and has
never been seen again the foundation is
on high alert for this test subject but
she seems to be staying below the radar
if she's even human at all anymore while
there is no physical sign of her the
foundation has observed odd patterns of
electromagnetic activity in the area and
is following reports of light fixtures
needing to be be replaced it was clear
that SCP 983 was much more unpredictable
than expected while still classified as
safe the foundation is keeping SCP 983
under tighter lock and key these days
all technicians who handle it are
carefully vetted to ensure that they are
nowhere near their birthday in case of
accidental exposure the foundation has
prepared emergency kits with detailed
instructions for how to complete the
birthday monkeyy deadly singalong game
but as with all things the foundation is
prepared for anything in the event of a
failure The Remains will be disposed of
by vetted staff any candies produced are
to be taken into custody by the
foundation and studied for unusual
properties but are not to be consumed
without full containment procedures and
approval from senior staff The Only
Exception is d-class testing but even in
those cases one rule remains intact no
one is ever ever to consume the black
candies and caution is encouraged around
the birthday monkey lest you wind up in
a singalong for your life from the
Garden of Eden to the top corner of your
English teacher's desk apples have
played an equal role in history's most
remarkable days and also its most
mundane the sounds of teeth snapping
through the skin sinking into flesh and
spitting out seeds echo through space
forever and onward and for most of our
Earthly hours consumed by appetite it
has been documented to be a lopsided
relationship between these two things
man and apple man getting the sweet
taste and abundant nutrients apples
getting nothing but pain and stomach
acids but this story is not found in our
history buried in the lawful patterns of
predator and prey we stumble upon an
irregularity an inversion an instance of
apples biting back SCP
4608 also known as apple seed was a a 60
acre apple orchard containing over
22,000 trees located just on the
outskirts of Milan Indiana a town so
small it strains your eyes as you squint
to find it with a microscope hovering
just over a map and to see what was
actually happening within the Curious
fringes of society took even greater
exploration not just of the eyes but
also of the mind because what would
eventually be seen would not so easily
be comprehended physical senses are just
the surface and we need to go deeper Our
Story begins with a great Logging
Company looking to take ownership of the
most fertile land they could find in the
Great Lakes region ideally land that
overproduces Conifer growth so that the
return on their investment would be
plentiful and Perpetual these
lumberjacked men knew what they wanted
beneath their red flannel shirts and
muddy boots was a deep intelligence and
understanding of nature their process of
assessing the land's value was
meticulously calculated they knew the
soil
both by the experience of their callous
hands and the literature of their study
they track various bird species
migration patterns in the area to assess
what kind of seeds they'd be carrying
and contributing to soil by way of their
stool they understood the local laws
relating to clear cutting and
conservation and how both would affect
their profit margins this is all to say
it wasn't just a speculative purchase
this was planned through and through and
dwell on and yet even then with
scrupulous eyes and care crew they
missed the warning signs SCP 4608
checked all their boxes and then some
what could go wrong and so they acquired
the land unwittingly purchasing the
Peril that came with it on the first day
of owning the property one crew member
noticed the branches did not Sway in the
same direction as the wind blew he
noticed the leaves didn't float down in
agreement with their feathery weight but
rather crashed to the soil like two
dimensional anvils in Grand pios The
Roots were not not ones you simply trip
over instead it seemed as if they stuck
their leg out to trip you when Birds
perched themselves up high and sang
their songs their Cadence carried all
the eeriness of an SOS with all this
said he was happy to have acquired the
land and having already picked up and
moved his family from the west coast to
now live and work out in Milan Indiana
he decided it was best to look past his
concerns after all it was the first day
on the new site and excitement was in
the air but with it also an amorphous
anxious energy during the first logging
Expedition within SCP
4608 this same member of the crew hiked
the grounds to better familiarize
himself with the environment he'd be
working on hoping that if he managed the
land properly and extracted the lumber
as efficiently as his late father did he
would be able to help build the business
and give his children the life he always
promised them he brought with him his
notepad and took detailed records of his
surroundings he figured to achieve his
his goals and sustained long-term yields
he'd have to cooperate with his
environment but he never questioned if
his environment wanted to cooperate with
him would this question have changed the
course of action or is brooding on the
preference of plants an empty gesture
best left for hippies at Woodstock
either way the orchard let it be known
how it felt about a collaboration when
hours later the man was found dead it
was first believed by his co-workers to
be a result of a safety equipment
malfunction maybe it was a simple matter
of thinking the skitter was in park when
it was really in neutral maybe the
knuckle boom loader went on the fritz
how it does when the humidity ramps up
maybe Machinery really was to blame in
which case you call it a fluke and ask
no more after all there's only so many
questions you can ask a robot but
initial belief is a Fickle thing and it
wasn't long until first impressions were
called into question by the courts of
critical thinking the questions of the
crew however only rang briefly because
shortly after the first death fell a
sequence of others in a matter of days
all of the remaining crew members were
declared dead or missing a word reserved
for search parties still clinging to
Hope a hot potato they would have been
wise to abandon for while it was hope
that brought these search parties
together it was hope that sent them off
never to be seen again the foundation
was then alerted to the occurrences
surrounding SCP 4608 by police reports
accompanied by a photograph a photograph
of an SCP
468-1 an organism consisting of
unidentified plant-like muscular
structures and a periderm resembling
those found on common Hardwoods from the
photograph alone it was clear that this
3M tall organism was capable of
committing the violence recently endured
forceful in its demeanor aggressive in
its presence and territorial in its
perception the photograph of SCP
468-1 led to an even bigger question is
this plant-like creature grown by nature
or sown by man after extensive research
by the foundation records were retrieved
that indicate the entirety of the 60
acre land was swn into Life by John
Chapman in
1826 Chapman was the type of man you
could mistake for a scarecrow both for
reasons of preferred Garb and Body
Language he was treated as such too his
personal space was respected maybe too
much he spent his life alone only
accompanied and comforted by the things
he planted he maintained these Acres all
by himself until his eventual death in
184 45 and it's then that it's believed
SCP 4608 became unstable reassigning its
objective from Comfort to chaos when the
newspaper came out the next Sunday John
Chapman's obituary painted him as a
priest of the Allen County church but
was this just the art of Illusion for as
far as we know no records of a chapel or
congregation exist a quiet choir indeed
come to think of it it seems that
everything within this 60 acre Orchard
was destined to be silenced one way or
another by violent force or even by
conscious decision making see while the
SCP Foundation has had a long track
record of subduing anomalies by methods
of capture and containment not all
things are suited for locks and chains
SCP 4608 is better covered with a story
than a tarm a fruitless field that once
produced at an unmanageable pace is now
rendered incapable of supporting growth
most will think it's due to a toxic
spell in Truth The Spill wasn't that of
chemicals on soil but rather corpses on
crops a week after receiving the
photograph of
468-1 site 81 sent a three-man
investigation team into Milan their
Adventure was equally abrupt a story
with no reportable beginning or middle
but simply a predictable end after 4
days of no communication the foundation
presumed the three agents no different
than their steak dinner dead meat and
only then after the foundation's failure
to solve the case was it understood that
what we were to be looking for wasn't
people at all but rather answers to more
nebulous questions what's really
happening here and why is this happening
following the loss of communication with
the investigation team site 81
dispatched a high-risk Response Team
Mobile Strike Force Bravo 7 AKA Hometown
Heroes these men had all the makings of
Heroes and they were determined to prove
themselves worthy of the title while the
alpha Squad moved north towards the
incident site beta Squad headed east and
Gamma Squad hurried West the cruise
covering all directions of the compass
but South a coincidentally symbolic
gesture as if to say we will not be
taken down the mission was simple in
theory find out what happened to the
previous team and why but alas missions
never are as easy as their objective
statement reads in practice some might
even call them impossible as Alpha
neared the incident site they noticed
the Shadows on the ground beneath them
did not resemble the shape shape of the
leaves in the canopy above they heard
small drops of liquid tap tap tap on
their helmets yet it wasn't raining was
it alpha 1 ran his finger across the top
of his helmet and then examined the
residue left on his skin it was raining
just not water oh God upon looking up he
witnessed the reasons for both
irregularities bodies hung from branches
by their intestines casting shadow
puppets with their lifeless limbs blood
dripped down like a leaky faucet what
did this but before he could even Ponder
the answer he heard a loud shriek from
his radio so loud that the radio itself
vibrated shaking its way loose from his
hand and falling to the dirt he bent
down and picked it up and this time
gripped tighter as if to tell whoever
was responsible for that noise that they
will not get away that easily he and his
crew followed this sound like a game of
Marco Polo linding to what may be ahead
they extended their guns and pointed
them into the distant Tree Line like
zombie arms reaching outward in the pool
towards the res its of Polo a small
comfort in a giant game of distress as
they press forward Alpha Squad proceeded
past all signs that pointed them back
stepping over dead bodies like puddles
on a rainy day soon they found
themselves crouching down next to human
remains attending brief and hurried
funerals for all their closest comrades
torn between staying to pay respect and
marching along to earn it the chest
cavities of the Fallen had been ripped
open and filled with apples a grim
foresight into what they were up against
but nothing they could have ever
imagined would prepare them for what
they were about to see and they wouldn't
have to wait long another loud shriek
from alpha 1's radio it jot free from
his grip and landed again in the dirt
the squad tried to ignore the
metaphorical implications of this
reoccurrence quickly picking up the
radio and shrugging it off as if the
5-second rule applied equally to
communication systems as candy bars they
pressed forward maybe out of Bravery
maybe out of Shame of going back and
while moving through the trees they
began to notice something alarming
etched on the their bark what was it
there were unnaturally deep grooves on
the base of almost every one of the
trees but what exactly were they from
scratches from an animal or beast
infection Decay their eyes Drew closer
but proximity brought them no Clarity
these sigils and symbols could be dated
back to a cult Norse religion but in
that moment they were incomprehensible
to the men yet the message even if
misinterpreted was very clear beware
another shrieking cry over the radio the
bullet the bullets aren't they're not
working they can't they can't penetrate
the bark the grass is no Greener over on
the east side of the orchard where beta
Squad gets lunged at by an SCP
468-1 their defenses are futile but they
fight nonetheless sending rounds to the
attacker's chest leading to nothing if
SCP 4608 had a health meter it wouldn't
have budged in the slightest
understanding the negligible impact of
their efforts and assessing their
injuries beta Squad scurries to retrieve
to an abandoned Chapel taking a brief
Refuge from war only later to be named
quickly they barricade the door in the
chapel beta 9 tends to Beta 6's wounds
who is in the worst shape of them all
cut bloody and beaten as he lays there
grimacing he shines his flashlight up
and down the Chapel's walls until he
finds a reason to stop and holds it
steady illuminated is an assortment of
human skulls and if this wasn't
traumatic enough he then spotted apple
seeds embedded in beta 6's wounds apple
seed seeds that were starting to sprout
beta 9 gave him to him straight this is
going to hurt he drew his knife from his
belt and lowered it into his comrade's
wounds beta 9 dug into flesh and Bone
picking the seeds out one by one beta
6's scream shook the Chapel's stained
glass windows as beta one stood guard he
saw a blur rip past him as if life had
suddenly been turned up to three times
speed he spun around in the circle to
try and keep his eyes on it but as his
vision refocused he saw beta 9 was now
dead he then shifted his gaze to Beta 6
who was looking less and less Human by
the second branches began sprouting out
of his body like an allc consuming magic
beam stalk out of his chest out of his
eyes out of his mouth and when there
were no more orifices to exit his body
exploded making way for the new form
that had overtaken him the barrage of
branches broke through the windows only
two of them were lucky to be on the
outskirts of inertia outside Gamma 1 was
on his knees thanking his dead comrade
for the grenade he stole from his back
pocket I could always count on you to
have my back even in death one hand
holding a grenade and the other on his
radio Gamma 1 called off Alpha 7 Alpha 7
request for backup rescinded go grab a
burger I'll take it from here Gamma One
slowly glanced up and locked eyes with
SCP 4608 D2 a large apple tree with 13
human faces embedded into it a perennial
plant with great Powers a gymnos spurn
that had found a voice blood poured from
SCP 4608 d2's empty eye sockets GMA one
smirks get some eye drops sio he crawled
over to the Beast the faces began
yelling at him in Indescribable tongues
let me refer you to a speech therapist
he jokes as he pulls the pin of the
grenade and throws it towards the
largest of the 13 mouths SCP 4608 D2
chokes on the grenade forcing it to
inhale deeply the strength of its lungs
pulling Gamma One toward it and sucking
him in the grenade goes off SCP 46 8-2
explodes the surrounding trees scream
and comust the orchard Goes Up in Flames
the bodies of the Fallen are given an
appropriate cremation gamma 1's radio
lays face up in the dirt The Voice
rattles it awake it's Alpha 7 GMA 1 GMA
1 are you there can you hear me please
please it's Alpha 7 please Gamma 1 on
October 16th 1947 Gamma 1 was recovered
by the Allen County Fire Department
unconscious and suffering from
exhaustion and smoke inhalation the site
81 concealment team took control of the
the situation and quarantined the area
using the cover story of a toxic
chemical Hazard the members of MTF Bravo
7 were post continuously awarded the
foundation star for their efforts during
the neutralization of SCP
4608 and so the one question that
remains is how how did SCP 468-1 become
so dangerous and how did its danger slip
by for so many years is its volatility
by Nature design or consequence could it
be that the foundation failed to
understand the complexity of this
creation during Chapman's lifetime there
were no accidents or fatalities coming
from SCP 4608 yet there is no reason to
believe that SCP
468-1 wasn't always capable of harm
maybe it always was capable of mass
murders but simply had no reason to kill
what if the Logging Company never
stepped foot on that land never brought
out their sharp blades and heavy
machinery what if this perilous Orchard
was in fact docile but provoked what if
the proverbial tree only falls in the
woods when we force our philosophy on it
though SCP 46082 spoke in unidentifiable
sounds the noises were always recognized
and recorded as language it spoke with
intent even if misunderstood what it
screamed is still unclear were they
pleased for help or messages of hate and
would one even be worse than the other
John Chapman might argue when facing
heavy machinery and trained artillery
would raising your voice even be a moral
decision at all is fight or flight
imbued not just in blood but also in
bark the fabric of our world is littered
with strange doorways if you know where
to look for them tears portals
anomalies all leading to places and PLS
Beyond human imagining and understanding
an SCP 2317 otherwise known as a door to
another world certainly fits that
description contained and kept at all
times under the watch of armed guards
SCP 237 appears to be a simple and
unsuspecting wooden door in its frame it
hardly looks like it requires such
extreme round-the-clock security or
needs a strange secretive ritual that
the foundation performs presumably to
keep the door closed but of course
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed doorway isn't where it
leads it's what it keeps out even by the
foundation's already high standards the
requirements and regulations for
personnel who are are assigned to SCP
2317 seem oddly specific psychological
testing is standard practice to work for
the foundation but an additional hurdle
that anyone has to clear before even
getting to Glimpse at this unassuming
wooden door is having a score of at
least 72 on the MGR obedience
examination it is also mandatory that
Personnel assigned to maintaining it are
both unmarried with no children or next
of Ken as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and
objectives these may seem like strange
requirements after all SCP 2317 is just
a door isn't
it perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about SCP 2317 buried deep
under layers upon layers of security
with only the overseer Council privy to
the full details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly still
if SCP 2317 is a door to another world
an alternate Dimension or parallel
reality it must be safe enough to visit
after all the foundation has been
sending Personnel in there on a regular
basis daily in fact according to the 05
Council this is done as part of a
procedure to maintain active containment
of something lurking beyond that old
wooden door frame
but what could possibly warrant such
constant maintenance and
surveillance in accordance with the
foundation's guidelines all staff are
required to rotate out of observing SCP
2317 after every 2 months and spend the
following third month in full
psychological counseling before they are
permitted to return to the containment
unit housing the door to another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly this was the title
given to the Daily containment procedure
that absolutely had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the
foundation he did make one request to
his commanding officer however he wanted
to know what had happened to the last
guard that had performed the
procedure didn't make it out of
psychological evaluation
the officer
replied not letting this affect his
dedication the guard was told to prepare
for procedure 220
calabasis along with a fellow member of
foundation security Personnel the guard
was instructed to gather everything on a
strange list the first was a
pre-selected member of Class D Personnel
specifically a convicted murderer class
D refers to disposable class Personnel
Expendable individuals recruited by the
foundation for the sole purpose of
testing
scps class DS were usually prison
inmates repurposed for SCP testing and
the one chosen for 220 calabases was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told a
foundation personel member instructed
him to refer to the class D solely as
the assistant from that point on next
the guard collected a live chicken an
obsidian edge knife a silver asarum and
aspersorium to be filled with 500 cc's
of holy water that have been blessed by
a priest of the abrahamic faith and
finally a 1 kiloton nuclear device which
according to instructions was only to be
detonated in the unlikely event of a
catastrophic containment failure in
other words The Last
Resort after following his instructions
to the letter and without question the
guard and his colleague were briefed the
foundation personel member informed them
that he'd be joining in leading them in
the procedure the staff member also
specified that hence 4th he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was in everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
SCP
2317 and the nature of procedure 220
calabases the class D joining them
wasn't actually a Class D the assistant
as they were now referred to was in
reality another Foundation staff member
with a level four security clearance
specifically tailored to SCP
2317 every member of Staff entering
through SCP 2317 and taking an active
role in 22 Calabasas needed to be
informed that this assistant was not to
be harmed or treated as a member of
disposable class fighting back the
nagging question of why the foundation
would employ this subterfuge the guard
along with his fellow security officer
the celebrant and assistant prepared for
their departure through the door to
another world at solar noon when the sun
was highest over SCP
2317 solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the
foundation as they entered the old
wooden door Beyond lay a Barren salt
plane stretching out for kilometers in
every direction this this alternate
Dimension according to the briefing was
designated SCP 2317 Prime the guard
immediately noticed a ring of Seven
Pillars directly ahead of the group as
they entered each of them bearing
intricately detailed Engravings unlike
anything from any era of ancient history
procedure 220 calabases was carried out
quickly but carefully the guard watching
as the celebrant and assistant were
careful not to miss a step first the
celebrant scattered holy water into the
center of the pillers with the aspergum
and aspersorium looking down at his feet
and keeping a steady Pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them the guard
watched intently as the celebrant
completed his circuit around the pillars
and turned to the assistant anointing
his head with Holy Water Seven Seals
Seven Rings seven Thrones for the
Scarlet King he said aloud the assistant
with the obsidian blade in his hand took
the chicken and dispatched it in
sacrifice letting its blood mix with the
holy water he then repeated the
celebrant circuit in the opposite
direction before stepping into the
center of the stone
pillars blood for the old gods water for
the new king the assistant recited
pouring the remaining mix of blood and
holy water over a patch of salt in the
middle of the Seven
Pillars even though he knew it wasn't
his place to question the foundation as
the 220 calabases procedure took place
the guard couldn't help but wonder what
all the was for it seems so ritualistic
like something deeply religious or even
magical he never bought into all that
occult mumbo jumbo even while working
for the foundation but he had learned
not to question anything even the
strangest and most inexplicable of
science little did he know that beneath
his feet was an ancient and unknowable
horror a beast Chained and lying in
weight contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature humanoid and obese its
body covered entirely in Scales thicker
than armor plating branch-like horns
protruded from its jawless head pointing
up to chains that hung from the Seven
Pillars above each one hooked into the
entity's back all but one of the chains
was broken a final withering shackle
keeping the devour of worlds in its
underground prison ever since 1894 BCE
when Arian Mystics imprisoned it the
devour has been waiting patiently for
its inevitable Freedom it knows as well
as the foundation that nothing can be
done to prevent the final chain from one
day breaking even procedure 220
calabases won't keep the creature
contained it's nothing more than a smoke
screen an act designed to create an
illusion of active containment and
maintain Foundation morale until a
permanent solution can be devised to
keep SC CP
imprisoned of course if the guard had
known this it would have also explained
the need for a 1 kiloton nuclear device
as part of this stage ritual procedure
220 calabases had all the components to
trick everyone below the 05 Council
emulating religious and occult rituals
The increased level of security
surrounding the procedure and its
purpose and telling staff that any
failure to correctly and completely
perform the 220 calabases procedure will
result in an XK Class end of the world
scenario all these elements work
together to conceal the truth that one
day the Devourer will escape and lay
waste to our
Dimension knowledge is power and maybe
knowing too much truly is deadly perhaps
if the guard had learned any of this
he'd have understood why his predecessor
never made it out of psychological
evaluation maybe if he had questioned
the purpose of procedure 220 calabases
he'd have learned the true nature of SCP
2317 and what that doorway kept out but
he was loyal to the foundation through
and through as the team finished
performing 220 calabases and returned
through the wooden door the guard took
one last glance over his shoulder at the
vast salt plane the entire Dimension was
calm silent but not peaceful it was
patient The Entity had waited centuries
for its time and now all it would take
was the breaking of this seventh and
final chain one day the door was closed
behind the guard as he the celebrant the
assistant and his fellow security
officers steep back through their work
done and as far as they knew preventing
catastrophe for another day only the
foundation hups the overseer Council are
aware of the true danger posed by SCP 23
17 and its sole
inhabitant current predictions are that
at some point within the next 30 Years
the Devourer of Worlds will be freed any
and all attempts to repair or recreate
the chains holding it in place have so
far failed as such the 05 Council has
elected to continue providing Foundation
personnel with the ignorant hope that
procedure 220 calabasis is an effective
strategy for containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out in the case of
SCP
2317 the unassuming wooden door holds at
Bay an ancient creature of Untold power
that will one day break free and wreck
havoc in our
Dimension nothing the foundation does
can prevent it or keep it contained
behind the door to another world and
only the overseer Council knows that any
and all efforts to do so are futile
with all that in mind we can only hope
that the doorway of SCP 2317 stays
closed at least for a little while
longer take a brief moment to think back
to your younger years spending long
tiresome hours trapped in a classroom
waiting to hear the noise of that final
Bell of the day that sound meant Freedom
the end of another grueling 6 hours at
your desk and the chance to get back to
the warm sanctuary of home if you were
lucky you might not have had to go far
to get back to the Safety and Security
of being in your parents' house living
close enough to the school would mean
you could easily walk home when the day
was through but your classmates well
they weren't all as lucky some of them
had miles to travel all the way across
town even fortunately though the school
bus would always be waiting outside at
the end of each day ready to take a
gaggle of rowdy kids back home and if
you were one of those kids that had to
take the bus you'll know that the trip
home after school was hardly a calm
drive paper planes and spitballs firing
from all directions wads of chewing gums
stuck to the undersides of seats other
kids all around you screaming and
yelling at the top of their lungs still
it could be worse right no trust us it
could be much much worse than you can
ever imagine what if one day the bus
that picked you up from school wasn't a
bus at all what if instead it was SC P
2086 picture this one day you get put in
detention at school maybe you were
disrupting a class or were're caught
spraying graffiti on the outside wall of
the gym whatever the reason we're sure
you'll think it is unfair that you got
held back after school after everyone
else had already gone home but you do
your time until finally you're told you
can leave problem is your house is on
the other side of town and you've
already missed the bus you make your way
off the campus down the nearest Street
Street maybe there's a city bus you can
catch that'll get you back home as you
stroll away from your school you realize
that the nearest bus stop the first one
on the route home seems to be further
away than you remember it being must be
just the exhaustion of a long day
getting the better of you playing tricks
on your mind it's not like someone could
move the bus stop right finally reaching
the stop you notice lights coming down
the street after a few moments of
waiting quietly a late bus just like you
hoped for it pulls up to the next stop
the doors folding open to allow you on
board it's totally empty save for the
driver but straight away you notice
there's something odd about him he seems
drained of color his movements are weird
more like a puppet on strings than an
actual living breathing human being now
that you think about it if it wasn't for
the fact he was clearly moving driving
the bus you might assume that he was a
corpse then again maybe he just had a
long day too taking a seat you try not
to think about it and stare out of the
window and boredom you watch as the
route takes you past stop after stop all
of them empty just like the bus itself
but then something unexpected happens
you've ridden the bus to and from school
so many times before that you can't help
but notice when for some reason it takes
a wrong turn looking out the window you
know you aren't mistaken the driver has
changed Direction instead of heading
towards the nearest Stop to home he's
taken the bus towards the furthest edge
of town
desperately you try yelling at him
asking why he's taking the wrong turn
but the driver stays still as if he
can't even hear what you're saying
that's when you notice the smell you
didn't catch it before but now it's all
around you filling the air inside the
bus it's almost like the scent of
disinfectant the bus now smells the same
way a hospital does but that's not all
the more you breathe it in the more you
feel yourself starting to get woozy arms
and legs is getting heavier everything
around you feels as if it's spinning
uncontrollably out of the windows you
can just about make out the sight of a
junkyard blurring in and out of focus
it's meant to be abandoned and yet
you're sure you can see movement massive
indeterminate shape shifting around in
the dark finally your vision goes dark
and you fall unconscious onto the floor
of the bus only you were never on the
bus to begin with no although you didn't
know it you were pray to something that
just looked like a bus SCP
2086 and now that it's caught you you'll
never see the light of day again now SCP
2086 doesn't just refer to a single
creature not by a long shot it is the
designation given to an entire species
of arthropods think lobsters crabs and
spiders or insects like centipedes and
millipedes only much bigger to the
untrained eye and depending on when you
look an instance of SCP 2086 will
normally look like any ordinary public
transport vehicle of any make and model
or belonging to any company or Transit
Authority usually though they look like
regular old buses at least while they're
out foraging for food when born an SCP
2086 specimen will grow to full juvenile
size within a week usually weighing 200
kg or less full matured adult instances
however can weigh approximately 177,000
kg the adults are the ones that go out
for ing leaving the nest to collect food
to then bring back to the juvenile SCP
286s and by food we of course mean
humans while out on the roads matured
SCP 2086 creatures are practically
identical to the auto vehicles that form
their bodies but the materials that this
disguise is made from the steel plastic
wood and glass they're all actually
comprised of specialized kiten the kind
of outer shell you'd find on most
arthropods but underneath that outer
shell and that's where you'll find the
Real Horror within the main chamber
beneath the flooring of the bus's long
inner portion is stored the pulsing
Beating Heart of an SCP 2086 specimen
and we don't mean that in a metaphorical
sense if you were to lift up the
floorboards of one of these bus-like
creatures you'd see its heart along with
other vital organs like the creature's
brain and stomach what's more the figure
in the front seat that you thought was a
living breathing bus driver actually
isn't living or or breathing not anymore
preserved in a shellock substance that
the creature is able to produce the
driver is actually a human corpse acting
as a Decoy for SCP 286s from within the
bus body fibrous appendages reach up
into the corpse almost like incredibly
thin hairs the creature can then use the
caver essentially as a puppet a puppet
with a dead person's body that's how an
SCP 2086 is able to move its driver
around making it appear more life like
so it can lure its prey aboard think of
it like the bioluminescent light that an
angler fish uses to tempt unsuspecting
fish into their jaws same principle but
with a dramatically different result
when it comes to SCP 2086 but if you
thought bus creatures with internal
organs under the floor and Dead Meat
Puppets in the driver's seat weren't
creepy enough there's still much more to
SCP 2086 is then meets the eye for
example when they aren't out foraging
the adult creatures can unravel the roof
roof of their bus-- shaped outer shell
underneath is a pair of wings large
enough and strong enough to carry their
entire 7,000 kilos of weight off the
ground and up into the air as For Eyes
the headlights at the front are in
actual fact bioluminescent Optical
organs allowing the creatures to see
their prey even in the dark still not
horrifying enough well would knowing
about their legs help the wheels
underneath an SCP 2086 specimen are also
capable of UN raveling forming long gray
or black legs like those of a spider yes
these are bus creatures with wings and
multi-jointed legs these legs aren't
just big clumsy appendages either
compared with other arthropods SCP 2086
are able to use their limbs to perform
surprisingly intricate actions and finer
levels of manipulations for instance a
number of specimens have been observed
in the Wild by the SCP Foundation
Building shelters out of any materials
that they can find near the nesting
ground and where do they normally Nest
wherever there's plenty of scrap metal
and hardly any people to notice them
junkyards are the preferred habitats of
SCP 286s and where they will normally
establish their colonies while the
juveniles remain within the confines of
the colony adult SCP 2086 specimens will
leave to collect humans although on
occasion the younger specimens have been
known to travel out from their nest and
rearrange or relocate signposts for bus
stops they then place them in a route
that leads them back towards their
nesting ground it's something worth
remembering if your nearest bus stop
ever seems to be a little further away
from the school than usual afterward the
older specimens will travel along the
Route laid out by the juvenile SCP 286s
picking up any human passengers that
they find waiting at the relocated bus
stops they have to choose their moments
wisely with people boarding and
disembarking from the bus usually every
few stops once an SCP 2086 has as many
hum on board as it can carry with the
certainty it won't lose any at the
upcoming stop it secretes a substance
similar to chloroform this fills the
inner chamber of the bus causing that
noxious smell like Hospital disinfectant
the chloroform like substance
incapacitates all the passengers on
board rendering them unconscious and
readying them to be taken back to the
local SCP 2086 Colony once the adult SCP
2086 has arrived at the junkyard the
juveniles will descend on it give given
their much much smaller size they will
climb inside the mature specimen and
forcibly remove each and every human
passenger it is carrying within then
comes the truly nasty part feeding time
each juvenile SCP 2086 will force their
captive human through an orifice that is
located under the front hood of their
vehicle shell this sphincter a circular
formation of muscle that can expand and
contract to perform a bodily function is
connected to where the steering wheel is
found on an adult SCP 2086 the younger
creatures will push their human prey
through the sphincter consuming them
once this has occurred those hairy
appendages in the driver's seat will
then latch onto the body of the now dead
human piercing through their skin
winding up and around their bones these
are the same fibrous hairs used to
puppet the deceased corpse and use it to
lure others aboard the bus but these
appendages have another function their
feeding tubes they will drain every last
drop of blood from the SCP 2086 fixes
prey until the body is little more than
a husk at which point the tubes inject a
saline solution directly into the
cadaver afterwards the inside of the bus
fills with that same substance that
preserves the corpse and the process is
complete as horrifying as these
creatures are one of the few upsides of
SCP 2086 is is that they don't live very
long female specimens will reproduce
after 8 days and produce 20 Offspring
after this point each of these newborns
reaches full maturity and size in about
week on average SCP 286s live for 12 to
15 days another net positive is because
of their short lifespans an SCP 2086
specimen doesn't need to feed on a human
more than once as the nutrients it
absorbs as a juvenile are enough to
sustain it through adulthood once it has
matured an SCP 2086 will go out into the
nearest city or town to forge for humans
providing food to the Next Generation
and so the cycle continues in the future
rather than taking the bus maybe it's
safer to walk it might mean the
difference between you making it home or
becoming food there is something so
captivating about ice it can be
beautiful a shimmering cast of frost
over a meadow or twinkling icicles on a
cottage roof it can also be deadly a
slick of slippery glass on a dark Road
or that same icicle from before knocking
loose and careening towards your head
like a falling dagger it can be a sleet
storm or a mighty Glacier with Secrets
buried beneath its core in a remote part
of Alaska the SCP Foundation discovered
a particularly unusual kind of ice with
a vivid red Hue and some incredibly
deadly potential the foundation
investigated the reports in a remote
area on the Alaskan Coastline after a
tribe of Local Natives came across the
mangled bodies of Shipwrecked hunters in
the area encased in a block of strange
red IR Ice mobile task force beta 7 also
known as the hazm matters were sent in
to the site to determine what exactly
had occurred and take samples of any
anomalous materials to be brought back
to the nearest Foundation research site
agent Bryce made the initial visual
inspection of the site and spotted three
middle-aged male bodies further
examination determined that one of the
bodies referred to as subject zero was
the original point of contamination for
whatever comprised the Red Ice and
caused the men deaths it has been
posited by the investigation team that
the other men were infected when they
attempted to help subject zero reach
their boat sadly kindness can sometimes
be a killer like that while sweeping the
perimeter agent Hughes spotted human
Footprints leading to the Northeast a
three-men team consisting of agent
Hughes Whitmore and Cassidy was
permitted to follow those tracks and
determine if any survivors or something
worse had escaped the site exploration
log a 009 allows us to determine what
happened next and what the three agents
found Hughes and his team followed the
footprints to the entrance of a cave
with the tracks appearing to lead inside
the entrance of the cave was covered
with an almost solid sheet of ice save
for a crack in the ice about 1 M tall
Beyond this wall agent Whitmore spotted
the body of a young man frozen solid in
the midst of crawling away from
something covered in crystals of Red Ice
Within was a frozen spear gun that
appeared to have been fired just before
the young man's death they could not
touch the body to perform a full
investigation but the way in which he
was gripping his chest indicated that he
might have been fatally stabbed there as
the agents moved further into the cave
they discovered a chamber about 5 or 6 m
in diameter filled with red ice with a
pool in the middle the pool was 3 m wide
and of an unknown depth as they pushed
further the agents came across a polar
bear startled they fired once at it
before realizing it was already dead its
fur was dotted with crystals of Red Ice
creeping its way across the Bear's body
beyond the polar bear the agent spotted
dozens of bodies all dead animals there
were seals a snow fox and finally a
giant spider with a leg span of over a
meter at first the spider appeared to be
Frozen like the other creatures but upon
further investigation it appeared to be
made of red nice agent Cassidy
recognized the spider as SCP 3023 but
was told it was impossible when she
pressed for further answers she was told
to ignore it and continue the sweep
agent Whitmore checked the collection of
bodies in the chamber looking for any
humans among them meanwhile Hughes
spotted a spear sticking out of the
enormous spider indicating a struggle
that took place before it and the young
man at the Cave's entrance froze Hughes
was interrupted in his task as agent
Cassidy called out from deeper in the
cave saying I I think I know where the
spider came from when Hughes followed
the sound of her voice he found
something troubling an aperture about a
meter in diameter absolutely covered in
Red Ice it looked like a tunnel with no
ice at all past its entrance with a dim
light coming from somewhere deep inside
he lost sight of agent Cassidy and
realized she must have gone inside of it
upon further observation Hughes
determined that the walls and the floor
of the tunnel were wet with a red puddle
about a meter in Hughes and Whitmore
called to Cassidy attempting to lead her
back out of the tunnel but received no
response Hughes attempted to go in and
retrieve her but control forbade him
from going any further after a
conversation with control that had been
stricken from the official file Hughes
had relented and agreed to withdraw his
remaining team and exit the site Hughes
and Whitmore left the cave without
further incident and returned to
Foundation headquarters in spite of a
d-class recovery team being sent in into
the cave to search for her agent
Cassidy's body was never found the cave
was blocked off from the public in order
to avoid further civilian contact with
the red ice and the red water inside
though the origin of the Red Ice in
Alaska is not known for sure this cave
and the pool deep within it are thought
to be the source of this particular
infestation the official cause of death
listed on record for the bodies found in
Alaska was internal bleeding but what
really happened to them was something
much much worse these men had
transformed and Frozen from the inside
out their blood turning to ice and their
cells going solid one at a time the low
ambient temperature in the area are
thought to have slowed the freezing
process down you heard that right the
cold kept them from freezing faster as
counterintuitive as it sounds this
prolonged their deaths and kept them
conscious up until the very end even as
their bodies were freezing solid their
very cells turning against them they
were awake and aware of it all these
unfortunate men came into contact with
and lost their lives to a substance
known as SCP
09 SCP 009 in its liquid form maintained
at temperatures between -100 and 0° C
resembles ordinary distilled water aside
from its bright red color it behaves
opposite of water reaching a frozen
solid state at higher temperatures and
vaporizing into a steam like gas at
temperatures below -100 de an attempt to
examine SCP 9's atomic structure was
unable to achieve conclusive results the
substance looks as if it was made up of
normal water molecules though obviously
it is much more than simple water SCP
009 appears relatively harmless at first
glance but its real dangerous potential
lies in its ability to contaminate
water-based Solutions transferring its
properties to them a contaminated liquid
begins to exhibit the same unusual
behavior as SCP 009 freezing at
temperatures above 0° and vaporizing at
temperatures below -100 it has been
shown to effectively contaminate ice
steam tea fruit juice seawater and blood
in a process taking between 3 minutes
and several hours these concerning
properties raise questions about what
SCP 009 and liquids contaminated by it
might do if they made contact with a
human body several d-class Personnel
were used as test subjects exposed to
SCP 009 in a controlled environment and
observed from a safe distance when first
exposed to SCP 009 the test subjects
reported nothing unusual except a slight
sensation of warming on the surface of
their skin then Frost began to form
across the surface of the exposed area
as the subject's body heat raised the
substance's temperature this process
took between a minute and a few hours
during which ice crystals began to form
along the top layer of the skin this
stage is known as surface conversion in
the next stage deep tissue conversion
the continued increase in SCP 9's
temperature causes a ripple effect of
reactions through the subject's body ice
crystals forming in the cells and
throughout the blood the subject
remained alive and conscious during the
stage details about the fourth stage of
the process have been expunged from the
official record but it is safe to say
that something horrible happened after
several of these experiments were
conducted testing on live d-class
subjects was officially discontinued
there was a possibility of
experimentation on SCP 009 regarding its
potential application to Cold Fusion but
this was also eventually discontinued
following a disastrous accident at an
unnamed Foundation test site the site
was completely destroyed and pieces of
the lead agent conducting the cold
fusion research have still not been
recovered for now SCP 009 is kept under
strict containment and only test Ed
Under particular highly regulated
circumstances SCP 009 is kept in a
sealed storage tank of heat resistant
alloy it is not to be exposed to any
temperatures higher than 0° C unless
there is official Foundation sanction
testing being done no water-based
liquids are allowed within 30 m of the
containment area the storage tank is
outfitted with temperature sensors that
are to be monitored at all times in
order to prevent the temperature within
from rising and is kept cold by three
different cooling units if the sensors
or cooling units malfunction for any
reason they must be fixed immediately to
prevent disaster when testing is done on
SCP 009 the containment area is kept in
a vacuum and the Personnel working with
it must wear protective gear after
testing all involved personnel must
quarantine for at least 12 hours any
living organisms contaminated by SCP 009
must be terminated promptly while the
exact origins of SCP 00 9 are unclear it
clearly does not follow the laws of
nature as we understand them a
foundation expert in xenos spatial
physics suggested that SCP 009 may have
come from a universe with alternate laws
of physics explaining its reversal of
the ordinary conditions for states of
matter during an instance of SCP 507 The
Reluctant Dimension Hopper shifting into
an alternate universe an instance of SCP
009 was unexpectedly observed that may
help confirm this theory in the test
area where SCP 507 appeared red snow
fell for about 27 minutes grass touched
by this red snow began to react and
freeze over within a few minutes the
other plant life touched by the snow
turned bright red and expanded to a
larger size it also began to sprout
bright blue tentacles covered with red
melage upon closer examination the
mucilage turned out to be comprised of
small amounts of SCP 009 this raised
additional questions for instance how
are these plants able to survive
constant exposure to SCP 009 this matter
is currently under investigation but the
prevailing theory is that this plant is
an example of plant life from SCP 9's
native Universe whatever it is and
wherever it comes from it should not be
allowed to come into contact with
earth-based Organic life forms well not
unless being horrifically frozen to
death by your own body feels like an
appealing experience to you the
coastline where SCP 009 was initially
discovered and its first victims on
record were found was located very close
to the ocean thankfully the exact area
of contamination was dry and cold enough
to keep the Red Ice from spreading but
if it had been even a few meters closer
to the water it could have spread into
the North Pacific Ocean with
contamination of that scale it could
have very easily infected thousands of
people perhaps spreading into other
bodies of water and triggering a global
Extinction event event because of this
threat several members of the SCP
Foundation proposed that SCP 009 be
upgraded to ker class in order to
reflect its danger to humanity however
this request was denied due to the
currently effective containment measures
in place the Red Ice is unable to spread
to new hosts infecting the water supply
and turning all living things into
frozen husks for now let's just hope we
don't see any red snowstorms anytime
soon a veteran work of the SCP
Foundation sits at his terminal
performing one of the most critical
tasks in the entire organization
creating a file for an as yet
undescribed SCP but there's something
terribly wrong his eyes are glazed over
his mouth hangs open is this a zombie or
a trained Foundation
researcher what is going on like any
large International Organization it
takes more than just the exciting action
filled jobs to keep the wheels turning
at the SC CP Foundation sure the head
researchers guards mobile task force
soldiers and members of the 05 command
get all the praise but a legion of
number crunchers cleaners and paper
pushers are equally important one such
person was archist Walter Banbridge who
had been tasked with digitizing some of
the older records that the foundation
had on file it was when he was
innocently recording the details on SCP
050 through
060 that he first came under the strange
and startling effects of SCP
055 but the most peculiar part as with
all incidents of SCP 055 anomalous
effects taking hold is that Walter had
no idea any of it was happening in his
new digitized filing system he first
took note of SCP 053 uclid class also
known as the young girl this anomaly was
a seemingly normal human female child
who provoked homicidal insanity in those
directly exposed to her then SCP 054
safe class a non-aggressive humanoid
female made entirely of as well as
biologically and chemically identical to
regular Spring Water next SCP 056 uclid
Class A being that changes form to suit
its environment but only when all
observers lose focus of it and then SCP
057 safe class an underground chamber
that CR es the humans who walk within it
was at this point that Walter received a
concerned message from one of his
superiors at site 19 Mr kovat the
message praised the thorough
digitization of the other anomalies
records but was confused about why
Walter had left out any mention of SCP
055 immediately Walter was embarrassed
how could he have forgotten SCP
055 that iconic anomaly known for well
he couldn't quite say off the top of his
head but he'd be sure to look into it a
quick trip to the site9 archive showed
him that there was actually quite a
hefty file on the nature of SCP
055 which must have been the result of a
huge number of studies what struck him
as strange was that all the files were
filled out in pen rather than being
typed up like a traditional file the
majority of these notes were written in
shorthand too as though they were
frantically taken during the tests
themselves on extremely short notice
there weren't even any redactions Walter
made a mental note of what he had seen
put the file back in its proper place
and headed back to his computer terminal
however after riding in an almost
trans-like State he looked back on his
work to see that he had written an entry
on SCP
058 a giant evil bovine heart with
insect legs and a scorpion Stinger
strange he thought that's when Walter
got a call from Mr kovat on his
foundation issue phone and he didn't
sound happy he'd given Walter direct
instructions to go back and digitize the
files on
055 and instead he'd been working on 058
what was the meaning of This Walter was
typically an extremely loyal and
diligent employee but the verbal barrage
from his supervisor had him considering
talking back just this once and hoping
it didn't get him demoted to d-class and
thrown into 682s Acid Bath for playtime
Walter G picked up some courage and
interrupted Mr kovach's rant to ask if
he had any idea what SCP 055 actually
was the line went silent for a moment
then his supervisor spoke again this
time with less confidence uh of course I
can tell you about SCP
055 it's a classic one of the first 100
how could you forget it's uh or you know
it's I think it's the one with um
another long pause as Mr kovat seemed to
search for the words but instead just TR
Ed off into silence knowing that some of
the anomalies on file were dangerous
mimetic hazards Walter was worried for a
moment that he may have accidentally
killed his boss by getting him to think
too hard about SCP
055 he asked if Mr koven was okay and
finally got a reply I'm sorry I seem to
have zoned out for a second there what
were we talking about again but this
time it was Walter who couldn't answer
he had no idea at all what the two of
them were discussing just moments ago he
felt disoriented and kind of sick like
they'd taken some low-level amnestics Mr
kovat told Walter to get back to his
filing duties and they'd speak later
Walter then checked the messages he'
received from Mr kovat earlier and there
it was plain as day you missed
055 go back and digitize that before
proceeding Mr K but Walter had never
even heard of an SCP 055 if such an
anomaly even existed what was going on
here in that moment Walter realized he
was dealing with something much Stranger
Than Just a standard digitization job
after all how could he properly complete
his duties if SCP 055 seemed to be
impossible to speak write or even think
about unless he were directly observing
it at that moment Walter had to know and
ask around the entirety of site 19 to
find the answers if he had to sadly for
Walter he was about to embark on a much
more challenging task than he could have
ever imagined to paraphrase a supposed
quote from Socrates all I know is that I
know nothing and that's also about the
extent of the knowledge we have on SCP
055 also known as the anti-em and the
self- keeping secret what does it look
like when and how was it obtained by the
foundation what are its anomalous
abilities is this thing dangerous we may
never know because the only anomalous
ability of SCP 055 that we're aware of
is the fact that nobody is capable of
retaining any information about it it's
crucial to note that whatever 055 is it
isn't invisible or
Indescribable Foundation Personnel are
perfectly capable of entering its
containment chamber and observing it
without incident but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber any memories of the
particulars of 055 seem to spontaneously
erase themselves hence the self- keeping
secret but this didn't deter Walter
perhaps his greatest Advantage was that
he didn't know enough about the thing he
was investigating to know how futile his
mission was he wanted to know the
unknowable and a pesky issue like
impossibility wouldn't stop him he'd get
to whoever he needed to at site 19 to
get the answers he needed of course most
people had no knowledge of the
mysterious anomaly the common response
he got back from his colleagues was 055
do we even have a 055 while the
realization of sudden memory loss or the
realization of 055 existence has been
known to cause momentary stress there
are no known long-term physical or
mental effects from 055 anomalous
abilities it's a fleeting idea in its
purest form like forgetting why you
walked into a room 055 could be the most
harmless object on the foundation's
roster or the most deadly either way we
just don't know at times Walter worried
he was going insane
055 and everything related to it was
gaslighting him was 055 even real the
one thing that proved to him that 055
must have existed is that its
containment chamber existed according to
the official records kept by the
foundation on the site 19 containment
facilities 055 is kept in a 5x5 by 2.5 M
Square Room constructed of 50 ft thick
cement with a faraday cage surrounding
the cement walls
the report continues that access is via
a heavy containment door measuring 2x
2.5 M constructed on bearings to ensure
door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately 055 cell
is one of the few to have no posted
security guards and any Personnel
working on other scps in the area are
ordered to remain at least 50 ft from
the geometric Center of 055 cell where
the anomaly itself is kept when he tried
to EXP explore further why the cell was
constructed in this manner he found that
surprise surprise nobody knew 055 was an
anomaly whose containment requirements
were so mysterious that it automatically
netted itself a ker class designation
after all how can you properly contain
something you can't even hope to
comprehend there were plenty of rumors
about the true nature of
055 some of the more conspiratorial
Minds at site 19 theorized that 055 was
actually an autonomous or remotely
controlled spy inserted into the site to
observe Foundation operations or even
Humanity as a whole if you're on the
more paranoid end of the psychological
Spectrum this Theory makes total sense
an anomaly that's physically impossible
to remember even when writings and
pictures on the subject exist would be a
perfect spy however this was all
ultimately little more than speculation
Walter was barely any further along than
when he started there were multiple
points in his investigations where
Walter seriously considered giving up
until finally he had a major
breakthrough Dr Bartholomew Hughes and
Dr John merich were two scientists that
had performed extensive research into
055 and who Walter hoped might have the
answers he sought about the self-
keeping secret these scientists were the
first to discover the antimimetic nature
of 055 performing numerous tests on
d-class Personnel to see if it was Poss
possible to create feasible written
records sketches or any other records or
Impressions that could bypass its
anomalous effects the disorienting
memory ruining effects of 055 also
extend to any materials concerning
055 it seems to be a truly uncrackable
code but Dr Hughes may have finally
found some cracks in the armor for
starters the fact that we're able to
remember that 055 is an antimimetic is
an ironic exception to its anti tic
qualities this Revelation also inspired
another realization from Dr
Hughes would it be possible to discover
more about 055 from the process of
deduction rather than the typical
induction in other words could they
possibly learn about 055 by figuring out
all the things it isn't rather than what
it is Dr mer designed an experiment with
Dr Hughes to explore this Theory they
designed the experiment around a simple
question is zero 055 not spherical in
designing the question to specifically
find out what 055 isn't they hope to
subvert the anomaly's anti- mtic powers
Walter was fascinated by this potential
method of getting answers Mar and Hughes
found that while the questioning process
for those exposed was often arduous and
frustrating they could now definitely
say that
055 is not a sphere it is theoretically
possible to discover the true nature of
zer 55 by an almost endless barrage of
deductive questions the WEA command
would authorize the resources for such
extensive testing is still an open
question Walter and his desperation
begged marich and Hughes for clearance
to view 055 himself the Curiosity had
become too great during his search to
just walk away with the single fact that
055 wasn't spherical he needed to see
this thing and after several weeks of
filling out forms and cutting red tape
his wish was finally granted Walter
Banbridge was allowed a private audience
with SCP
055 the subject of his monthlong
obsession Outsiders observe that Walter
spent just over an hour in the
containment chamber taking photos
drawing sketches writing down notes
recording audio logs and reciting memory
pneumonics he was pulling out every stop
to counteract the anti-mimetic effects
of the self- keeping secret he was
adamant that he would not be defeated by
his non-spherical Nemesis not after all
this time and effort once his time in
the 055 containment chamber was over he
retired back to his office to finally
digitize his exhaustive findings so that
his supervisor Mr kovat would finally
get off his back Walter smiled took a
deep breath and began to type SCP 059
ker class this anomaly is a radioactive
mineral that emits a unique radiation
known as Delta radiation
exposure to this radiation has caused
strange fungal growths on the
infected wait what was this supposed to
be about again oh well it couldn't have
been that important does the black moon
howl no not yet see the boy he was born
in a time before names there weren't
enough humans around to need them back
then he was one of a handful occupying a
Coastal Village using a tongue long
since dead they eak out a simple life
hunting Gathering fishing the only thing
on most of their minds was surviving to
see the next sunrise yes a simple life
free of complications until the hermit
appeared the boy would remember this man
for eternity Haggard and thin skin
weathered by time and pain a man that
emaciated walking with a long gnarled
cane that honestly looked healthier than
he did shouldn't be alive alive even the
boy who had scarcely seen beyond the
bounds of his village knew that the
hermit was unnatural and aberration an
anomaly he walked into the center of the
village sat down on a large Stone and
waited nobody dared ask his business nor
what the hermit waited for then a few
days later the black moon howled the boy
saw The Village's youngest Hunter freeze
one evening while out on a walk not
simply stand still but freeze then for
an instant he became solid black a coal
statue and as soon as he' changed he was
gone obliterated not a trace of him
remained such is the power of the black
moon it can make any conscious being
disappear in an instant turned black
then wiped from our plane of existence
never to be seen again its choice of
victims seemed at each instance to be
utterly random but it would come for all
who lived eventually this is known to
some as the howling of the black moon
later that same night the boy found
himself talking to the hermit who asked
with small frantic eyes what he had seen
when the boy told him he let out a deep
rattling sigh the boy curious asked him
if he knew about the nightmare he'd just
witnessed The Hermit looked up he'd been
the first one in the hermit's millennial
of pursuit that had ever asked in that
moment he knew that he had found his
successor in the hunt for the death of
Ages The Hermit told the boy it went by
many names the great finale The Pale
King but most common of all was the
black moon The Entity existed Beyond the
Veil of our reality a creature of pure
energy though nobody could really be
sure of its true nature The Hermit had
been tracking it learning about it and
trying to destroy it for thousands of
years and yet it only took him four
pathetic minutes to tell the boy
everything he knew the boy knowing still
that something about the hermit was
unnatural asked how he came to be in
this position The Hermit told the boy he
was the counterbalance a kind of Chosen
One destined to face and perhaps even
defeat the black moon someday the
counterbalance receives a number of
truly extraordinary gifts for inheriting
the responsibility eternal life eternal
youth near physical immortality but they
will be haunted by their purpose doomed
to watch everyone they love die around
them as they continue to hunt their only
true equal and opposite the black moon
itself The Hermit in his own eyes had
failed at his duty he had grown weary
and now he needed to pass the duty of
counterbalance on to another that us
mother would be the boy he felt a sudden
and profound change along with the
knowledge that nothing would ever be the
same again he was no longer just the boy
now he was the counterbalance he watched
The Hermit give him a slight nod of
respect and then crumble into dust
before his eyes the boy the
counterbalance looked up at the sky and
saw the Stars twinkling so bright and so
beautiful little did he know his battle
with the black moon would Outlast every
single one of them does the black moon
howl not without blood the boy grew into
a man as his village aged and then died
around him decades passed then centuries
then Millennia tens of thousands of
years watching Humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit
of that one elusive foe as science and
diagnostic technology gained ground
absorbing and then evolving Beyond
beyond all the old superstitions the
counterbalance gained a better
understanding of the black moon though
even then it still remained essentially
a stranger The Entity was entropic a
being of pure Randomness and Chaos
without consistent form it didn't exist
in our universe but it could exercise
its influence here with so-called
obliteration events much like the
horrible fate that befell the young
hunter from the village but that was
only the proverbial tip of the iceberg
the counterbalance tracked and noted
obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning Trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year once a
month a week a day an hour a minute a
second it'd spell the end of all
conscious life a total victory for the
black moon the end of the universe the
death of Ages a complete existential
obliteration he was swept up in a
sobering realization he couldn't win
this fight alone however while his hunt
for the black moon had been largely
fruitless
the counterbalance had discovered many
other things along the way strange
creatures objects with extraordinary
powers and events that couldn't be
explained with rational science perhaps
something about these Oddities these
anomalies would hold the key to
defeating his Timeless enemy and it
hadn't just been these objects entities
and events he'd also discovered some
truly exceptional people on his travels
minds and skills that rivaled even his
own despite his age perhaps they would
be the ones to help him win with the 13
most brilliant and trusted people the
counterbalance ever met he decided to
form a council and from this Council
they forged and directed an organization
dedicated to understanding and
counteracting the strange in all its
forms with the secret hope that their
search Into Darkness would yield the
answer to the black Moon's downfall he
called it the SCP Foundation they would
secure the anomalous contain it and
protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title be fitting of his new
role the administrator and even the
black moon itself was given a moniker in
hopes of robbing it of some of its
frightening power SCP
001 does the black moon howl only at the
blind the year was now 1987 the SCP
Foundation had been operating for over a
century and thanks to their secret
possession of anomalous wisdom and
Technology their own advancement was
thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity well there still wasn't a
silver bullet solution to the black moon
and its deadly howls were becoming all
the more frequent as the decades went on
the foundation did have some irons in
the fire to combat it their ability to
gather Intel on both the entity itself
and its obliteration events had improved
considerably thanks to their new new
Global Information Network their top
Minds were also working on a highly
classified device known as the singular
conceptual bunker which may one day come
in handy for combating the
extradimensional entity directly but the
most valuable piece of information they
ever gathered about the black moon was
this it couldn't howl when it was being
watched the very Act of engaged
observation defanged it the problem is
How Can You observe something that
doesn't technically exist inside your
own reality in order to pull this off
the foundation would need to get
extremely creative thankfully Creative
Solutions to strange problems are the
foundation's specialty Flash Forward to
1993 enter Dr Moto a brilliant young
scientist and conceptual engineer
working for the SCP Foundation with the
administrator's consultation he started
the key project an arm of the wider
project aoes the umbrella Initiative for
using modified anomalous objects in the
battle against the black moon the goal
of the key project was relatively simple
if people couldn't observe the black
moon directly then the foundation could
make proxies of the black moon that
could be observed almost like a kind of
voodoo doll these new anomalies would
only need to satisfy three criteria the
inability to operate when being observed
a hostility to conscious life and the
ability to end conscious life of their
own valtion when not being observed
through conceptual engineering a link
theoretically could be forged between
these objects and the black moon
allowing observation of them to stop the
obliteration events however despite
being a good idea in theory Dr Moto's
efforts were marred with errors and
tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted Escape by barging
through site 01 the center for
anti-black Moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
Moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of Moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalagtites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for. 2 seconds
almost all of Moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientist felt a deep
shame but forged on he made one truly
brilliant creation that satisfied all
the criteria a sculpture incapable of
moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even a
fraction of a second its relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing Mass deaths and all the
other deaths that had sadly occurred
during the key project Dr Moto believed
that the lives saved in the long run by
stopping the black Moon's howls would
justify the sacrifice the problem is the
key project didn't stop anything not
long after this there was the first
recorded double obliteration event in
Rome where a young tourist couple had
both been obliterated simultaneously all
the deaths in the key project had been
for nothing the black moon was only
getting more more powerful the shame and
the guilt was too much for Dr Modo he
left a note in his office Reading we've
been looking at nothing I'm sorry
administrator I failed you sir Moto's
corpse was later found in the sculptures
temporary containment chamber his neck
snapped the key project was in summary
shut down and its one surviving creation
transported to site 19 in late 1993
where it was designated as SCP
173 another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine Millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the counter balance to
the black moon science marched on the
SCP Foundation marched on but all this
progress all this power was nothing
against the incomprehensible influence
of SCP
001 the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year
3156 when the foundation launched the
seek project under the support of
project orastes as more and more people
were wiped out in frequent obliteration
events the administrator became
painfully aware that perhaps the answers
to the black moon problem wouldn't be
found on Earth using state-of-the-art
technology With a Little Help from the
anomalous the SCP Foundation began work
on an autonomous space fairing vessel
that could search the the stars for the
key to the black Moon's destruction it
was an on inspiring creation a huge
craft powered by artificial intelligence
with a universal translator cogenic
units and hundreds of autonomous drones
to perform more targeted searches seek
was waved off into the unforgiving
depths of space the administrator could
only hope that it would come back with
worthwhile answers the first of the
three notable planets SE arrived on was
one theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snow storms when
se's drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creatures but
no signs of actual life remained records
and statues found across the planet
seemed to indicate that the black moon
was responsible for the destruction of
the planet's civilization causing so
many obliteration events that the
remaining survivors went mad from the
fear and stress leading to mass death in
the ensuing chaos the next planet was
discovered centuries later in the year
34.99 while this planet could also
theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface a flaming mess however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
Advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior Planet they
had been driven extinct by Black Moon
obliteration events a century before the
seek even arrived unlike the last planet
however it seems that they accepted
their fate and went gently into the
night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored bat-like creatures
that operated on pure Instinct and thus
were not considered conscious enough to
be obliterated the final planet was
reached in
3764 and was the most fruitful of the
three discoveries this planet was hyper
Advanced fully urbanized and covered in
sprawling mega cities with records and
Technology over a thousand years ahead
of Earth before the black moon killed
almost all of them there were a species
of humanoid telepathic fungi and had
developed an awareness of the black
Moon's existence that was on par with
that of humanities they even had their
own equivalent of the SCP Foundation
actively working on countermeasures and
most amazingly of all seek found one
surviving member of the species on the
planet cryogenically frozen the craft
was immediately instructed to collect
the Survivor and return home for
interrogation the administrator Was
preparing for what could be the most
important conversation since he met the
hermit all those thousands of years ago
does the black moon howl only when
waning when the surviving creature
codeen named Sage was returned to Earth
the administrator was eager to finally
speak with it like the rest of its now
extinct species Sage spoke through
powerful telepathic mind waves which
only the administrator thanks to his
counterbalance abilities was able to
receive at close range without being
harmed incidentally it wasn't long until
the very fact of the administrator's
nature as a counterbalance came up in
the mental conversation Sage could tell
just by being in his presence they
discovered a number of vital truths over
their brief time communicating that
Sage's survival had been pure luck for
starters the black moon is still very
much capable of obliterating conscious
beings in an unconscious State the
administrator also learned that he was
merely the latest in an extremely long
line of counterbalances across time
space and species though everyone but
him had waved this Duty passed it on
Sage had one question to ask the
administrator in turn what is
SCB the singular conceptual bunker being
worked on and perfected for thousands of
years by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual Engineers the
administrator replied Victory but it
will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked saged asked him what good
victory would do him then rather than
say it aloud he replied with a thought
Sage paused and said I see how
Blasphemous of you hopefully it works
after this the administrator proceeded
to the singular conceptual bunker and
entered it leaving instructions for the
foundation to be run by a newly formed
05 Council in his indefinite absence
thousands of years later in the year 51
s stage spoke one more time repeating
the words hopefully hopefully before
turning solid black and disappearing the
black moon had claimed one more victim
but billions more had gone in the
interim the administrator had no more
answers to give at least no more answers
that anyone but him would understand he
was inside the singular conceptual
bunker now loaded into a device known as
toome an experimental Memorial module
meant to pick up and record all the last
messages of every dying civilization
Across the Universe when the time
finally came all he could do was wait
and wait was exactly what we did does
the black moon howl yes yes it does
years pass too many to count it's a time
after names now and toome sits in the
very center drinking in the end of the
universe the last of all the human
colonies Across the Universe were
obliterated by the black moon back in
the year
7329 so so so long ago but some of the
final messages of fear panic and
distress still echoed around in the
administrator's mind hello is there
anyone here we require assistance
there's it's it's taking people every
day we need help there's barely anyone
left we need help hello hello cabal 0943
we have abandoned the false flesh we
have abandoned the false flesh the
shepherd's crook broken Neath my knee
cabal 0943 cabal 0943 forgive us forgive
us we're going to leave this on it's so
dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's I have to go now respond First
Convenience emergency situation
developing require additional resources
my fault your fault our fault my fault
your fault our fault my fault your fault
our fault rip my brain out now rip my
brain out now and a small child the last
on Earth simply asking hello into an
indifferent microphone but the
administrator had to wait as the
singular conceptual bunker became the
solitary conceptual bunker he was the
last conscious being in the universe and
still he needed to wait as the Stars
went dark outside only when there was
nothing outside but black was it finally
time for the counterbalances long game
to play off there was nothing left of
our universe the only thing here was the
SCB and the black moon itself with
everything else gone the black moon only
had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this this doesn't make sense how
can the black moon an entity beyond our
Dimension Beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black Moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can I pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black Moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrator just
seemed to be enjoying himself preparing
for a confrontation hundreds of billions
of years in the making the singular
conceptual bunker or perhaps the
singular containment bunker was a truly
ingenious creation a place of pure ideas
where everything inside was on the same
level here there were no Immortals no
Gods just ideas on the same Level
Playing Field and it was time for the
black Moon's idea to come to an end it
was a trap and the entire universe was
the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and Unleashed both
both barrels into the black Moon's chest
the creature took the hit and fought
back dragging the administrator to the
ground beating him strangling him he
could feel the light fading under the
monster's Relentless assault until he
managed to get his desperate hands on a
glass ashtray he beat the monster over
the head with it until its grip loosened
and he was able to slide out there the
killer of the universe was on the ground
before him he grabbed the monster held
it in place and beat it to death he was
Gravely injured by the battle but the
black moon was no more here in the
singular conceptual bunker he had won
the administrator no longer the
counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the Jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said the
thing is this place is only
information there's nothing else out
there not even m matter the universe
closed its doors a long time ago but
this place can go from information back
to matter with just the Press of a
button let's see what happens when we
introduce something to nothing for a
second it looks as though he might fall
but he doesn't instead he slams the
button on the jukebox and with a
relieved laugh says let there be light
and there was light now go check out SCP
001 which is the real 001 and SCP 001 ex
a good boy to unravel more of the many
Mysteries of the legendary SCP 001